Exzellent, Moin, Icons, ne, Ecos, irgendwie habe ich das aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen,
da steht im Hemd, da steht Icons, ich muss gerade nochmal die ganzen Geräte anstöpseln,
dass sie mal aufladen, Handy ist noch auf Low Battery, Not Pogu, irgendwo habe ich ein
USB-C zu normalem USB und irgendwie, ich finde es einfach nicht, weil es wäre ganz gut,
ich habe ja hier so eine Steckdosenleiste, die hat noch vier freie USB-Stecker und da
könnte ich die auch noch mit benutzen.
KA, wo ich das habe, Dantudev, Dankeschön, Pogsubscription, hast du schon das Windows-Video
von Morpheus gesehen, welches, welches denn, weiß nicht, vielleicht haben wir das sogar
auf, bin mir doch gar nicht sicher, ich habe ja ein paar Sachen hier, guck mal, guck mal
doch mal, so, ne, was, was, Goodbye Windows, Chatkontrolle nur schlimmer, Microsofts neuer
Servicevertrag, ja, das habe ich, das habe ich nicht geguckt.
Aber ich habe das gelesen, ich habe da irgendwo was drüber gelesen, dass Microsoft jetzt irgendwie
noch, ach, ich kriege es gar nicht, ich kriege es aus dem Kopf nicht mehr zusammen, aber
ich habe was drüber gelesen.
Letztendlich wird es wahrscheinlich keinen wirklich jucken, der es benutzt und sie werden
es einfach alle weiter benutzen.
Und Frexor, ich muss sagen, wird besser, mir tun die Beine heute gar nicht mehr groß weh,
aber, letztes Mal war viel anstrengender.
Und Wurzeln.
Wurzels App, das Scam Train, ich habe gesehen, Bezos will gar nicht mehr ins Weltall, für
was, für was Scam Train Twitch denn jetzt weiter?
Einfach nur noch Geld, also ich meine, Weltall wäre nice gewesen, aber, würde, Chat, wenn
ihr die Chance hättet, zumal, erste Frage, ja, wenn ihr die Chance hättet, ins Weltall
zu fliegen.
Sei es jetzt irgendwie so als Weltalltourist so mäßig.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ein Tag auf die Internationale Raumstation und zurück oder
irgendwie so.
Ist egal, ob das jetzt realistisch ist, dass das geht oder nicht, aber, gehen wir mal von
aus, ihr könntet das machen, würdet ihr das machen oder nicht?
Also, würdet ihr euch in eine Rakete setzen, ins Weltall schießen lassen und dann da irgendwie
einen Tag rumfliegen und dann wieder zurück?
Also, wir gehen davon aus, hin und rück ist gesichert, ja, also, natürlich die Gefahren,
die es birgt, ja.
Also, ihr werdet auf jeden Fall wieder zurück geflogen.
Würdet ihr das machen?
Ich wahrscheinlich auch.
Ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch machen.
Mit Bitcoin-Logo.
Wie?
Mit Bitcoin?
Ich dachte, Dogecoin.
Mal kurz anschauen.
Na gut, man darf ja nicht, man darf ja nicht vergessen, ganz ungefährlich ist es ja nun
auch wiederum nicht, sich in so eine Rakete zu setzen und, ich hab's ein bisschen laut,
ganz ungefährlich ist es ja auch nicht, sich in so eine Rakete zu setzen und vor allem
auch wieder zu landen.
Ja.
Aber ich würde das wahrscheinlich trotzdem machen.
Man muss, zumal, zumal, also, generell ist es ja relativ safe die letzten Jahre über.
Es passiert ja kaum was.
Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass es so ungefährlich ist, weil wenn da irgendwas schief geht, hast
du zu 99% immer gelitten eigentlich.
Da ist da echt nicht so viel, was du machen kannst.
Kannst du nicht mal in den Flieger steigen?
Ich glaube, die Kräfte und Belastung in der Rakete sind zwar sicherlich höher, als die,
die man in der Rakete hat.
Aber ich würde das wahrscheinlich trotzdem machen.
Die sind zwar sicherlich höher, als bei so einem 0815 Verkehrsflieger, aber ich glaube,
die sind, die sind ganz andere, als in einem Flieger.
Ein Flieger ist ja eher quasi horizontal, mit ein bisschen Auf- und Abgefalle zwischendurch.
Rakete ist im Prinzip ja fast nur, fast nur vertikal, wo es sich, wo es sich halt nach
hinten drückt und halt auch ordentlich durchschüttelt.
Keine Ahnung, also ich, ich würde das wahrscheinlich, ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch machen.
Das ist jetzt ein Vergleich.
Da wollte ich eigentlich nicht drauf raus.
Die Chancen stehen ja ganz gut, dass man es überlebt.
Also wenn die Chancen so schlecht ständen, wie beispielsweise, wo sie das alles erprobt
haben, mit wie baut man so eine Rakete und sowas, dann würde ich da auch nicht mitfliegen.
Aber in der heutigen Zeit, also wenn ich die Chance hätte, würde ich es wahrscheinlich
machen.
Ja, du bist du nicht allein.
Es gibt viele Leute, die haben Angst vor Flugzeugen.
Gibt da Leute, die haben Angst vor Fahrzeugen und sowas.
Das kann man ja nicht immer so richtig rational bekunden.
In Fahrstühlen passiert auch nichts.
Also ich glaube, es ist, sterben nicht mal eine Person im Jahr an einem an Fahrstuhl Dingern,
sondern irgendwie null Komma null irgendwas und dann und dann meistens noch nicht mal
durch Fahrstuhl Sachen selber, sondern durch irgendwelche umstehenden liegenden Sachen.
Also da passiert ja eigentlich nichts und bei Flieger passiert auch enorm wenig, aber man
kann es.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn Leute Angst, sagen wir mal, haben vor Spinnen oder so bei uns
zumindest in unseren Breitengraden, die tun ja auch nix, aber ich mag Spinnen auch
nicht.
Also das kann man nicht so wirklich, wirklich erklären oftmals.
Aber es ist halt so genauso.
Also eine Sache, eine Sache habe ich auch letztens gemerkt, wir müssen übrigens gleich
noch mal eine Runde Shithub Trending wieder gucken.
Eine Sache habe ich bei mir gemerkt, das habe ich hatte ich früher auch nicht.
Ich also ich habe nicht wirklich Höhenangst, aber mir wird es ein bisschen so ich.
Ich halte mich doch schon ein bisschen mehr am Geländer.
Fest.
So.
Letztens bin ich mal auf einem meiner Wander Ausflüge auf so ein Turm hochgelaufen.
Das war kein super hoher Turm, das war jetzt nicht Frankfurt, irgendwie 150 Stockwerke
oder sonst was.
Das war einfach ein ganz normaler alter, alter Turm, wo man hoch konnte, aber dementsprechend
war der halt auch jetzt nicht super gesichert, hat einfach so eine.
Stein war, wobei ich kann euch kann euch das eigentlich mal zeigen den Turm, als es davon
Bilder gibt.
Warte mal.
Ja, genau.
Da ist ein.
Da ist ein Turm.
Hat Google nicht eigentlich Fotos und sowas normalerweise?
Also hier ist ein Restaurant, aber hier gibt es eigentlich.
Hier ist kein Turm.
Hecke.
Hä?
Warum ist es so schlecht auf einmal?
Wir gehen mal.
Wir gehen mal direkt auf Google Maps.
Zumindest.
Da ist ein.
Ja, aus aus irgendwer.
Also normalerweise ist hier ist hier ein Turm, wo man rauf.
Da hat doch Google.
Da hat doch Google immer Bilder.
Ähm.
Warum sieht man den Turm hier nicht?
Ach doch hier.
Hier ist der Turm.
Okay, der Turm sieht aus Satelliten aus Satelliten Perspektive gar nichts, aber man sieht ja
schon am Schatten.
Das ist relativ hoch.
Da kann man.
Da kann man so ein halbes Jahr lang ungefähr auch ungefähr rauf.
Aber vielleicht gibt es ja da hier.
Ja, da sieht man das doch.
Ja, das Teil.
Da bin ich letztens rauf.
Der ist nur.
Hier die untere nur die untere aus.
Darauf.
Untere Aussicht.
War quasi 21 Meter hoch.
Es hält sich echt den Grenzen im Vergleich zu irgendwelchen Gebäuden in Frankfurt oder
so.
Aber ist mir aufgefallen, wenn man da rausgeht.
Irgendwie habe ich mich doch erstaunlich, erstaunlich fest irgendwie am Geländer gehalten.
Ja.
Das Geländer ist jetzt auch nicht.
Sieht jetzt vielleicht hoch aus, aber das Geländer geht im Prinzip auch nur bis zum
Bauch.
Also wenn man will, könnte man da ohne Problem runterfallen.
Und das hatte ich früher auch nicht.
Das war.
Das war es mir schon ein bisschen komisch.
Ehrlich gesagt, wenn man da oben runter geguckt hat.
Also es ändert sich da auch mit der Zeit so ein bisschen was dran.
Deswegen muss ich denke ich, muss man sich keine Gedanken machen, weil man Angst hat
vor Flugzeugen, Fahrstühlen, sonst was.
Man kann das oftmals nicht so richtig rational erklären.
Meine Chance, dass ich da runtergefallen wäre, sind auch nähern sich null.
Ja, aber es ist natürlich auch ein bisschen Gewöhnungssache.
Wenn ich da jetzt jeden Tag hochlaufen würde, würde es mich wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal
schocken.
Was im Gegensatz nicht schockt ist.
Gibt ja in Frankfurt auch ein paar Hochhäuser, wo man, wo man raus kann und runter gucken
kann.
Und.
Oder gibt ja auch welche.
Gibt ja sogar Türme.
Da gibt es direkt Aussichtsplattform und so.
Das hat mich alles nicht geschockt.
Auch bei uns in der alten Firma aufs Gebäude oben drauf aufs Dach und da runter gucken
auch nicht.
Irgendwie komisch.
Also manchmal interessiert.
Manchmal schockt es nicht.
Manchmal schon.
Hat bestimmt noch was mit den Umständen zu tun.
Und vieles Gewöhnungssache.
Ich glaube, die meisten Menschen sterben nicht zu Hause.
Ich glaube, sie sterben im Krankenhaus.
Ich glaube, statistisch gesehen müsste man jetzt ja quasi sagen, das Krankenhaus ist
der gefährlichste Ort.
Aber da sieht man, dass man mit sowas wunderbar Ursache und Wirkung umdrehen kann, weil den
meisten Leuten geht schlecht.
Deswegen sind sie im Krankenhaus.
Das heißt nicht, dass es den Leuten im Krankenhaus durchs Krankenhaus schlecht geht.
Aber wenn man sich mal rein die Zahlen anguckt, die meisten Leute sterben im Krankenhaus, wird
man sagen, ja, Krankenhaus ist super gefährlich.
Okay, seit seit multi resistenten Keimen und man kann sich Corona und alles einfangen,
ist Krankenhaus wahrscheinlich echt nicht so ohne.
Aber insgesamt sind halt viele Krankenleute im Krankenhaus und deswegen.
Also in Frankfurt gibt es ein paar Aussichtsplattformen, die haben so Glasböden.
Aber glücklicherweise habe ich dort noch keins gesehen.
Zumindest wo ich gewesen bin, die so komplett durchsichtiges Glas haben.
Es war immer gut als Glasboden zu sehen.
Es gibt ja, es gibt ja so so Aussichtsplattformen, die haben Glasboden, der extra gefühlt so
gemacht ist, dass du das Glas nicht siehst.
Und das ist da schon ein bisschen was anderes.
Gibt ja auch Leute, die müssen darauf rumspringen, so nach dem Motto Hey, vielleicht kriege ich
es kaputt.
Und Leute, die eh schon Schiss haben, kriegen kriegen es dann immer mit der Angst zu tun.
Aber vieles, vieles kann man nicht so wirklich rational erklären, warum man da Schiss vorhat.
Guck mal.
Ich krieg mein eigenes Video empfohlen.
Pog.
Muss ich mal anklicken für ein bisschen View Time.
Wobei, wenn es danach, wenn es, wenn es nach View Time geht, müsste ich es eigentlich laufen lassen.
Weil wenn man es nicht laufen lässt, dann ist ja schlechte View Time.
Ich lasse einfach mal mein eigenes Video kurz laufen.
Easy.
Gestern war der tausendste Stream im Archiv.
Pog.
Dazu kann man ja nur sagen.
Und natürlich.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich?
Fun Fact am Rande.
Hat wahrscheinlich von euch keiner wirklich mitgekriegt.
Außer den Modges.
Das Archiv.
Ist jetzt nur noch.
Wobei, da muss ich, da muss ich ein bisschen ausholen.
Das läuft ja auf einer eigenen Kiste.
Da kümmert sich, kümmert sich unser, unser Ober-Cute-Mod drum.
Höchstpersönlich.
Und der Max-Bauer hat die Software da drauf gebaut, die da drauf läuft.
Also nicht ich, sondern, sondern der Max.
Und letztens hat er mich angeschrieben.
Der Ober-Cute-Mod persönlich.
Wir müssen DNS-Einträge ändern, weil der Archiv-Server hat sich geändert.
Und ich hab gesagt, ja okay, gib halt neue IP-Adresse her.
Ich trag schnell ein.
Und dann meinte er so zu mir.
Ja Max, aber das Server ist nur noch IPv6 erreichbar.
Und, und jetzt kommt, und jetzt kommt der Hit.
Jetzt kommt der Hit.
Wir haben jetzt ein eigenes BGP-Netz.
Hab ich, boin.
Ich hab gedacht, was?
Warum haben wir für den Archiv-Server.
Ein eigenes, das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja.
Und dann kam irgendwie raus, dass.
Keine Ahnung, was die da getrieben haben.
Sie haben, er und ein Kumpel haben sich irgendwie als Provider angemeldet.
Und haben jetzt ein eigenes IPv6 BGP-Netz.
Und da steht der Archiv-Server drin.
Also leichter, leichter Overkill.
Leichter Overkill.
Das einzige Problem daran ist jetzt.
Dass das Archiv eigentlich nicht mehr per IPv4 erreichbar ist.
Das heißt.
Wir haben jetzt einen Cloudflare-Tunnel davor.
Der IPv4 auf IPv6 macht.
Damit das überhaupt noch funktioniert.
Aber, aber ich weiß nicht.
Es scheint ja alles zu funktionieren.
Ne.
Suchen wir mal Kekkel.
Ja.
Kekkel.
Bessel.
Gucken wir mal, ob die.
Gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Wenn man da drauf klickt.
Müsste ich jetzt gleich Kekkel sagen.
Kekkel.
L.
Ja.
100%.
Ist ja passiert.
Dann mose ich mal nach.
Einfachelas Kekkel.
All v.
Create.
Kekkel.
Name.
Funktioniert.
Also muss ich sagen.
Das Indexen ist schon wirklich nice.
Sehr based.
Ja.
Oh der Chat war kurzzeitig kaputt.
Ich bin so müde.
Immer noch.
Ja.
Meta-Quest 3.
Das habe ich glaube ich sogar schon offen hier.
nach dem initialen Hype vor
4-5 Jahren mit
der Oculus Rift damals, das könnte sogar
schon 6 Jahre her gewesen sein, wo alle gesagt
haben, ja diesmal, aber diesmal
wirklich Virtual Reality, diesmal
diesmal ist es echt soweit.
Hat sich da nicht allzu viel getan?
Oh, Leute,
das Arbeitsamt
erzählt uns was über Fizi.
Das muss ich mir angucken.
Mal gucken, wie realitätsnah
das ist, was die uns erzählen. Wahrscheinlich
erzählen die uns wieder, du bist,
du wechselst Monitore und tauschst
Druckerpatronen. Oh je, das wird was.
Fachinformatiker
innen der Fachrichtung Systemintegration
realisieren, Kunden spielst, okay, bla bla
bla bla. Allerdings schreckt
mich die softwarebezogene Seite ab. Warum?
Ich hatte im Abitur
erste Kontakte mit MySQL.
Ja gut, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil der
Unterricht gesackt hat, ne?
Ja gut, ich mein, es kann natürlich auch sein, dass es nix für ihn ist.
Aber so rein die Hardware
Seite ohne irgendwas wird halt
sehr schwierig, weil da läuft halt
was drauf. Die Hardware ist
ja für irgendeinen Zweck da.
Ich muss, ich muss sagen, ich hab
die letzten Jahre über immer
weniger Interesse an der reinen
Hardware gehabt. Mehr, mehr an
Software, Softwareseite.
Auch an Softwareentwicklung. Ich bastel
natürlich immer noch gerne.
Aber, ja,
wir haben ja auch Microcontroller gebastelt. Wobei
es da hauptsächlich darum ging, eigene Firmen
zu bauen. Irgendwelche
Smart, Smart Home Sachen umgebracht.
Ich bastel auch noch gerne. Aber so
richtig mit PC-Hardware, da
ist bei mir die Faszination ehrlich gesagt
schon ein bisschen raus. Gibt Leute, da geht
das, geht das genau umgedreht. Ich glaub
der Bauer, der ist da immer noch voll dabei,
was PC-Hardware angeht. Ja,
meine, gut, der ist ein paar Jahre jünger als ich, glaube ich.
Aber, wenn man sich den Channel anguckt, der findet
natürlich PC-Hardware, geht der immer noch voll drauf ab.
So als, ähm,
Übertaktungsspezialist.
Aber es ändert sich oftmals ja auch
ein bisschen, was einen so interessiert
mit den Jahren. Und Hardware hat bei mir
nachgelassen. Früher fand ich PC-Hardware
mega spannend. Ich hatte auch bei mir
damals im Kinderzimmer noch
uralte Hardware rumliegen.
Die hat sich gestapelt. Ich hab nix weggeschmissen.
Ich hatte da teilweise
Sachen, irgendwie diese
super fetten 10 Megabyte
Festplatten hatte ich noch. Die waren damals
schon outdated. Ich glaube,
eine Sache hab ich beim Umzug mitgenommen.
Warum auch immer, weiß ich nicht.
Und die hab ich einfach noch nie weggeschmissen.
Ich glaube, ich hab noch
ne Nvidia
GeForce 3 oder irgendwie sowas
im Schrank liegen. Warum? Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber ich interessiere mich aktuell
nur für PC-Hardware,
wenn ich mir einen neuen PC kaufen will.
Dazwischen verfolge ich das gar nicht mehr.
Also ich könnte euch jetzt legit
nicht sagen, was die schnellste
CPU fürs Gaming ist. Und ich könnte
euch auch nicht sagen, wie
die aktuellen Top Intel CPUs
heißen oder Top AMD CPUs.
Ich könnte raten, ich vermute mal,
bei Intel ist
das wahrscheinlich ein i9.
Immer noch. Weiß ich, ob es da
mittlerweile nicht auch i11 oder i13
oder sowas gibt.
Also, vermutlich
vermutlich
nicht. Also wahrscheinlich ist es immer noch ein i9
und wahrscheinlich, also ich hab
einen 13.900, ne
hab ich 13.900
K, das heißt wahrscheinlich
ist es mittlerweile ein 14.900
K oder so der aktuell ist. Ich hab echt keine Ahnung.
Und bei AMD und bei den Ryzen
Benahmungen blick ich noch weniger durch.
Wahrscheinlich sind wir jetzt was,
bei Ryzen 4
7.000
9.600 oder irgendwas.
Ich blick es nicht.
Ich weiß da genau einmal drüber Bescheid.
Nämlich, wenn ich mir einen neuen PC
kaufen will. Und letztes Jahr im Dezember
wusste ich kurzzeitig darüber Bescheid.
Hab mir einen neuen PC zusammengestellt,
gekauft und jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr drüber Bescheid.
Warum, wieso lädst du die Videos nicht auf YouTube
und verlinkst sie auf deinem? Die haben wir als Backup auch auf YouTube.
Ja.
Wir haben das auch als Backup auf YouTube.
Also nicht bei mir auf dem Main Channel, weil
MonkaTOS und sowas soll
davon nicht beeinflusst werden. Und ich betreib den ja auch nicht.
Es ist auf YouTube.
Aber das im Archiv ist viel, viel
nicer, weil das Archiv halt
sowas hier zum Beispiel hat.
Wenn ich jetzt nach Arch Linux suchen will,
such ich hier nach Arch Linux
und da kann man sowohl den Titel der Screens
durchsuchen, mega schnell, weil
Pfeiffer hat Fulltext Search.
Sondern man kann auch das durchsuchen mit
Timestamp, was ich wann wo sage.
Und das geht auf YouTube nicht.
Das ist halt sehr Six Head Time.
Das ganze läuft übrigens auf der Cloud Kiste
mit, also initial lief das auf der
Cloud Kiste, glaub ich mit
3090 RTX,
RTX 3090 oder zwei RTX
3090 Grafikkarten. Die haben das
initiale Archiv transcribed.
Ja, war einfach zu anstrengend.
Zu eklig aktuell zu halten.
Ich schick meine Hardware nirgendswohin, weil
das ist mir viel zu anstrengend. Da müsst ihr einpacken
und irgendwo hinschicken. Sagt mir nix.
Aber ich werd mir nie Fertigsysteme kaufen.
Selbst
wenn es super Fertigsysteme gibt,
ich glaub das werd ich
PC wird immer selbst zusammengebaut.
Diesmal war es ja auch schon hart an der
Grenze, Leute. Erinnert sich noch jemand?
Chat, erinnert sich noch jemand an die
Haarrisse im Mainboard?
Also dass mein Rechner überhaupt funktioniert, scheint
ja schon laut Chat ein absolutes Wunder
zu sein.
Nach den ganzen Haarrissen im Mainboard.
Ja, genau, hier gibt's nen YouTube Channel.
Der YouTube Channel war aber auch schon mal gebannt.
Weil...
Postsachen. Deswegen hat das mit meinem Main Channel
auch nix zu tun und ich betreib das auch nicht.
Das ist nur noch mal als Backup.
Ja, du findest das garantiert.
Wenn du ArchByTheWay suchst im...
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob der ByTheWay
richtig transcribt. Ja, macht er.
Guck mal.
In 867 Fällen
hab ich... hat er erkannt, dass
ich Arch oder ArchDealungsByTheWay
sage. Ich glaube,
der checkt sogar, dass
ArchDealungsByTheWay und ByTheWay, das ist das richtige
5-Head-Fulltext-Search,
dass es das gleiche damit gemeint ist.
Wie heißt die Archivsoftware?
Die heißt gar nicht.
Das ist Wubblos Spezial-Archivsoftware.
Der durchsucht alles Gesagte.
Ja.
Ja. Wenn ich Q-Chat
Ayaya sage,
dann erkennt er das.
Wie gesagt, initial
wurde das ganze transcribt, glaube ich,
auf ner Linus-Kiste
mit zwei RTX 3090.
Mittlerweile weiß ich's gar nicht.
Max, worauf läuft denn das aktuell?
Ist das noch mit GPU-Processing oder geht das
jetzt ohne, weil's immer noch Stream-by-Stream ist?
Hast du dir die MW3-Beta
angeschaut? Nein, hab ich auch ehrlich gesagt
keinen Bock drauf.
Ich muss sagen, das Remake
seit MW1, ich finde...
Ich rede jetzt nicht von Warzone, vom Multiplayer, ja?
Mir gefällt das Spielgefühl überhaupt
nicht. Das ist so
anstrengend und oftmals
auch slow-paced,
ist das falsche Wort. Man kann
sich ja da schon bewegen, das ist...
Es ist so anstrengend
einfach nur.
Und ich mag den gesamten
Spielfluss nicht. Guck mal,
aktuell wird's auf ner 3080 transcribt.
Bifed-Time. Guck,
wird mit ner 3080 transcribt.
Up-Aim-Heavy.
Ja, das trifft es.
Das ist das Wort, was mir gefehlt hat.
Es ist sehr Up-Aim-Heavy, ja.
Das trifft's wirklich ganz gut, ja.
Ja.
Ey,
das ist nicht Open Source.
Das ist auch zusammen
gesetzt aus unterschiedlichen
Sachen. Ich glaub, Max, es kann sein,
dass ich Mist erzähle. Ich glaube, es ist ein
Svelte Kit
Frontend. Es ist
ein Backend, weiß
ich gar nicht,
was es ist, mittlerweile.
Whisper
macht das Transcribing vom
Stream. Miley macht die
Full-Text-Search.
Also, das ist aus unterschiedlichen
quasi Hyper-Agile
Microservices. Ja, nicht wirklich.
Ach, ist es? Ist es wirklich Open Source?
Guck mal da.
Hier, Leute.
Ich hab nix gesagt.
Ich hab nix gesagt. Das Wubblos Archiv
ist tatsächlich
Open Source. Okay.
Also, Svelte Kit Frontend,
Python Backend. Ne.
Go. Go Backend.
Go Backend.
Und Python
Zeug für das Transcribe.
Wie sieht denn das aus?
Ich hab da nix reingelegt.
Ist doch eigentlich recht übersichtlich.
Whisper Pile.
Geht doch. Ist doch eigentlich alles
richtig gut lesbar. Easy.
Eats.
Very Eats.
Easy.
Hat jemand von euch die MW3 Beta gespielt?
Kommt die nicht erst für n PC?
Release.
Ach, ne.
Hier ist gestartet
am Donnerstag.
MW3 Beta in Gefahr.
Cheat Anbieter verteilt kostenlose Hacks.
Naja, das war jetzt doch damit zu rechnen,
oder? Ich mein, MW1
und 2, das ist alles so ähnlich.
Das wird wahrscheinlich 1 zu 1 funktionieren.
Am besten, Leute, eines der
witzigsten Storys, was Cheating
Software angeht, fand ich immer noch Battlefield 2042.
Da wurde ja zum Release,
also mittlerweile ist es ja bei
Cheating Software auch so, dass das oftmals
als Abo-Modell verkauft wird.
Also du kaufst sie jetzt nicht über irgendwelche
dubiosen Quellen.
Wie hieß das Ding früher?
X42
oder sowas? Ne, wie hieß das Ding
noch zu Black Ops Zeiten?
Ich hab's vergessen.
Ihr habt das nie benutzt, keine Ahnung, wie das heißt.
Irgendwas mit X.
X22. Ja, sowas. Genau.
Ja, ja, X22.
Also heute kaufst
ihr das nicht einfach. Heute kaufst du ein
Abo für Cheating Software.
Oder zumindest ist das da relativ beliebt.
Und
Battlefield 2042 ist
so kacke gelauncht und war
so schnell so unbedeutend,
dass Anti-Cheating Anbieter, also daran
erkennst du, wenn ein Game wirklich
dead ist, ja. Also
Anti-Cheating Anbieter haben
Battlefield 2042 Cheats aus dem
Programm genommen und haben gesagt,
jeder der ein Abo abgeschlossen hat,
darf das kostenlos umstellen auf
ein Abo für Cheating Software für ein anderes
Spiel seiner Wahl.
Sie entwickeln den Cheat nicht weiter.
Das Game ist dead.
Also daran erkennst du, wenn was wirklich
gefailt ist, wenn zwei Monate nach Release
die Anti-Cheating, nicht Anti-Cheating,
die Cheating Software
eingestellt wird.
Und du dein Abo kostenlos umstellen kannst.
Daran siehst du, das Game ist wirklich
unbedeutend.
BF5 wird wahrscheinlich mal weiter
entwickelt. Ist die eigentlich
auch auf dem PC?
Ah ja, hier. Zudem gibt es für
das Game ein Abo.
Wann startet es denn auf dem PC?
Ach hier, ab gestern.
Ab gestern,
wenn man nicht vorbe...
Also jetzt könnte ich auch...
Aber ich habe keinen Bock, ehrlich gesagt.
Mich hat der Multiplayer von MW1 und MW2
so abgefuckt und ich fand das auch sehr
Ab-Aim-Heavy
trifft es.
Mir gefällt das vom Game...
Mir gefällt der Multiplayer vom Gameplay
gefühlt nicht. Ich werde mir das auch nicht kaufen.
Also diese Remake-Geschichten
oder sagen wir mal
Battlefield 3 nur in besser. Ja, ich hätte auch gern
Battlefield 3 nur in besser und neu und so.
Aber es muss ja nicht...
Ich will ja gar kein Remake. Das ist ja unsinnig.
Die sollen einfach ein neues
gescheites Battlefield bauen
und nicht so einen Kack wie 2042.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich fande auch
Battlefield 5 und 1
ging es schon bergab.
Wenn auch 1 zumindest mal das Setting
und die Atmosphäre
irgendwie für sich verbuchen konnte,
aber insgesamt, muss ich sagen,
war Battlefield 3...
Manche werden sagen Battlefield 2, die die noch
länger dabei sind, war das für mich
Peak Battlefield.
Ab Battlefield 4 ging es leicht bergab.
Immer weiter.
Ja, es ist auch lustig, dass in MW3
die Remastered von
MW2 Maps
einfach nur noch...
Ich habe schon oft gesagt, es ist komplette
kreative Bankrotterklärung, dieses ganze...
Also mittlerweile
die ganze Modern Warfare Reihe und
es hieß es nicht mal,
dass Call of Duty nur noch alle 2 Jahre kommen soll.
Mittlerweile sind wir wieder bei jedes Jahr.
Aber gut, verkauft sich ja anscheinend auch.
Aber richtig Kohle machen die wahrscheinlich
hauptsächlich mit Warzone.
Warzone struggelt ja auch ein bisschen jetzt.
Letzter Zeit habe ich mitbekommen.
Aber es wird immer noch massig Geld machen.
Du machst gerade dein was?
Fachinformatiker anwend...
Warum muss man das so krass abkürzen?
Fachinanwend.
Mach gerade Netzwerktechnik.
Warum?
Ist doch gar nicht verkehrt.
Was ist daran so schlimm?
Ja, das da hast du recht.
Da gebe ich dir recht.
Generell
es ist halt sehr head glitch
up-aim heavy.
Zu kompliziert.
Also...
Ist Übungssache.
Und gerade Netzwerkbasics
sollte man können, auch als Anwendungsentwickler.
Weil da musst du ja auch, wenn du was
programmierst, das ein oder andere Mal drauf achten.
Das haben wir aber viel weniger
gespielt.
Ja, ich vergesse immer, dass das der gleiche,
dass das zu diesem ganzen Activision Blizzard Ding
ja auch, ich habe vergessen
wie die Candy Crush Leute heißen, gehören.
Ja...
King Games?
Oder waren das andere?
Ich glaube die gehören da auch dabei.
Wobei es mittlerweile ja alles
zu Microsoft gehört. Seit gestern.
Seit gestern ist es ja offiziell durch.
Activision Blizzard gehört zu Microsoft.
Ja, habe ich gesehen.
Deswegen, es gab sogar auch
irgendwie Free Weekend oder sowas.
Ich habe mich letztens gewundert, warum auf einen Schlag
80.000 Leute auf Steam online waren.
Was ist da los?
Ja, Packet Tracer
ist auch sehr praktisch zum Netzwerkbasics
sich angucken.
Vor allem, weil man Step-for-Step alles durchklicken kann.
Wie was passiert.
Wir haben Packet Tracer, haben wir ja auch schon im Stream.
Guck mal, zeigen wir mal das geile Archiv.
Packet.
Tracer.
Guck hier, sieht man es doch.
Packet Tracer.
Da werden die Pakete getracert.
Und das nice am Packet Tracer
ist halt, dass man einzelne
Steps, man sieht es ja hier, man kann jetzt im Simulator
auf weiter klicken.
Und dann sieht man, Paket geht
dahin, dahin, dahin und kann dann auch reinschauen,
was da drinnen steht. Das ist kostenlos übrigens.
Kann sich jeder runterladen.
Man braucht einen Cisco Academy
Account, aber den kann man sich kostenlos erstellen.
Ja, auch mit
Fake E-Mail Adresse.
Also das ist sehr praktisch, das Ding.
Ja.
Ja, es ist
seit gestern ist das durch.
Ja, nice.
Also ich finde Packet Tracer eine richtig gute Sache.
Also ich würde nicht unbedingt sagen, dass
das zu Kernaufgaben von einem Anwendungsentwickler
gehört, aber es ist auf jeden Fall
sinnvoll und zu einem gewissen
Grad auch notwendig, dass man Netzwerk Basics
checkt.
Die grundlegenden Sachen am Switch
zu konfigurieren ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Könnt ihr euch noch an das Video erinnern,
von diesem gestellten
Ausfall, wo
der Ausbilder den Port runtergefahren hat
und dann neben dem Azubi stand,
dem die ganze Zeit irgendwie
gesagt hat, was er tippen soll und eigentlich schon wissen müsste
und so.
Nico hieß der Azubi, genau.
Habe ich mir gemerkt, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Alter, der Ausbilder
geht mir auf den Keks, Mann.
Nico hätte das ohne Probleme
alleine hingekriegt, ohne den Typ daneben.
Ist Übungssache.
Spricht ja nichts, du kannst ja den Packet Tracer
auch bei dir daheim mal drauf hauen und ein bisschen rumklicken.
Da kommt man schon dahinter.
Aufgeregt habe
ich mich ja schon ein paar Mal.
Was fällt dir denn schwer an den
Cisco Netzwerk Sachen?
Was ich schwierig finde,
generell jetzt bei Cisco Konfiguration,
nicht so sehr Netzwerk Basics,
man muss sich halt
erstmal ein bisschen an die CLI gewöhnen.
Von den Switchen.
Ich habe die Hälfte auch schon vergessen.
Was man macht ist N, EN
und dann CONF T.
Mehr weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ja und No Shutdown
für den Port.
Und Show IP
Fragezeichen, wenn man nicht weiter weiß.
CLI ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
kompliziert, weil man halt in diesen
Cisco Way sich
rein denken muss.
Subnetze vergeben ist easy.
Starte einfach deine
Lenungskiste.
Okay, das darfst du aber in der Arbeit wahrscheinlich nicht
verwenden.
Aber Subnetze musst du zumindest während der Ausbildung
ein bisschen checken, weil das kommt auch in der Prüfung dran
und das wollen die immer mal wissen.
Ich kann es auch nur noch mit sehr viel
Hirn verdrehen.
Aber später
macht man das einfach so.
Hallo.
Ich würde gerne
hier rein tippen dürfen.
Später sagst du einfach IP Calc.
Easy.
Das ist ein bisschen
eine Netzaufteilung.
Natürlich kannst du das nicht in der Arbeit verwenden.
Du kriegst sogar Binary Ansicht.
Aber wie gesagt, in der Arbeit kannst du es nicht verwenden.
Das heißt, du musst das irgendwie zumindest mal
kurzfristig für die Arbeit in deiner Abschlussprüfung
während der Ausbildung checken.
Danach kannst du es wieder vergessen.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das Eats ist,
weil ich habe das mal verstanden und ich glaube,
jetzt würde ich mir da bei komplizierten Sachen
auch schwer tun.
Ja, die
ist nicht bekannt dafür, realitätsnah zu sein.
Ja genau, das ist so eine typische
Also Klasse B würde man ja heute
nicht mehr wirklich sagen.
Aber das ist so eine typische Frage.
Insgesamt sollen mindestens 2000
tausend sein. Wie viele Bits muss da raus?
Ja, ja, ja. Das ist so eine typische IHK-Frage.
Also ist das
bei dir anders? Darfst du den IP Calculator
verwenden in der Arbeit?
Oder in der Abschlussprüfung?
Was das sagt? Das sagt Easy as
Fuck sagt das.
Easy as Fuck.
Easy as Fuck sagt das.
Das kann auch sagen.
Das ist ein
koreanischer, eine koreanische
Text-to-Speech
Engine, die wir
auf Aussprache Ultra Happy
umgestellt haben. Deswegen klingt die
auch so glücklich, wenn sie Easy as Fuck
sagt. Easy as Fuck.
Oder 360
Noscope
Nice. Oder, oder
Subscriber.
Deswegen klingt die super happy.
Man konnte bei
dieser Text-to-Speech-Engine
konnte man irgendwie so Begeisterungsgrad
einstellen. Wir haben den voll hoch
gedreht. Deswegen kann
ich auch sagen.
Subscriber.
Internet während der Prüfung.
Okay, da würde ich mir Gedanken machen, ob man nicht einfach
einen Chat aufmacht und die Leute fragt.
Also.
Was ist das
für eine Text-to-Speech-Engine? Ich habe keine
Ahnung mehr, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Wir können mal nachgucken.
Irgendwo hier ist das Source-Count
davon. Das ist uralt.
Das ist noch .NET Framework
4.8 oder sowas.
Ähm.
Ich habe hier gar nichts mehr drauf.
Wo könnte das
drinnen sein? Models?
Nein.
Help?
FFmpeg?
Nee.
Services?
Text-to-Speech-Service.
Das klingt gut.
Ja, Notepad ist das beste für C-Sharp-Code.
Das wissen wir alle.
Text-to-Speech-Service.
Wir verwenden
apikey-leaked
oder was auch immer.
Wir verwenden
hier.
api.voicetext.
japan.
speaker-hikari.
emotion-happiness.
Die sind umgezogen.
Aber die API-Funst ist anscheinend immer noch.
Wobei, ich habe mir das ja lokal
zwischengespeichert.
Happiness-emotion-level 4.
Mehr ging nicht.
Und deswegen klingt die so ultra glücklich,
wenn sie sagt Subscriber.
So, lass uns mal
Shit-Hub-Trends angucken der letzten Woche.
Ob da irgendwas
Spannendes drinnen ist.
Was trendet denn hier?
Was haben wir denn?
AI. Juckt mich nicht.
Spacedrive.
Das hat letztens irgendjemand empfohlen.
Dass ich mir das mal angucke.
Cross-Platform-File-Explorer.
Written in Rust.
Ist das wieder so ein Tool,
wo der einzige Charme ist,
dass es written in Rust ist?
Oder was kann das geiles?
Das ist ein File-Explorer.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Elektron,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ist es aber anscheinend nicht.
Scheint High-IQ-Shit zu sein.
Keine Ahnung.
Brauche ich wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
AI. AI.
Rust.
Oh guck mal, hier kann man lernen,
wie man Android mit Rust programmiert.
AI. AI.
Sales.
Monka. Monka.
W, Alter.
Open Source IDE-Testing.
Das ist quasi Postman
mit eigenem
IDE-Style-Fenster.
Homepage.
AI.
Was ist so Schlimmes an Salesforce?
Nix.
Das ist genauso was so Schlimmes an SAP.
Das ist so Ultra-Business-Enterprise-Nerv-Software.
The Most Advanced
Embedded Vector Search Engine.
Okay Leute, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung,
was das überhaupt sein soll.
Aber es ist in Java entwickelt.
Für meine meisten.
Tja.
Blazingly.
Es ist entweder Blazingly Fast
oder es funktioniert nicht.
Okay, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an.
Zeig mal ein Bild. Zeig mal ein Bild davon.
Open Source IDE
for Exploring and Testing APIs.
Light-Wide Alternative to Post.
Okay, ich hätte jetzt eher gedacht,
dass Postman eine
Light-Wide Alternative ist. Aber gut, dann
gucken wir mal, was daran Light-Wide ist.
Sieht ein bisschen aus,
wie ein Visual Studio Plugin.
Es ist bestimmt Elektron, oder?
Chatgear, was meint ihr? Elektron Basis oder nicht?
Ich tippe ganz stark auf Elektron Basis.
Ich muss,
ich muss hier ehrlich sagen, ich bin ja Team Curl.
Ich benutze eigentlich hauptsächlich Curl
und weder Postman noch
dieses komische in JetBrains
IDEs für einfach Curl und gut ist.
Ja, mir ist auch klar,
irgendwelche Kommunikation
gescriptet
ablaufen lassen
ist natürlich in Curl nicht
so easy wie vielleicht in anderen
Sachen und aufzeichnen ist mit Curl auch nicht.
Ja, man kann nicht alles mit Curl
machen, was man mit den anderen machen kann.
Aber in der Regel, irgendein
apn.curl und bisschen jason
hinschicken, das geht mit Curl wunderbar.
Ich werde mit dem ganzen
Zeug nicht warm. Ich habe seit
langer Zeit Postman installiert
und ab und zu benutze ich das auch mal.
Aber
hauptsächlich 99% Curl.
Jaja, klar,
ich verstehe den Anwendungszweck schon.
Wenn du dir irgendwelche Sachen
sharen willst, zum Beispiel irgendwelche Tests,
dass du sagst, hey, wir haben hier 50
Sachen und nicht jeder muss sich was eigenes ausdenken.
Jaja, verstehe ich alles.
Aber bei mir reicht trotzdem zu
99% Curl.
Und eine Sache, die mich auch bei
Postman nach einer Weile abgeschreckt hat,
ist, dass die mich mittlerweile dort auch
für irgendein API-Testing-Tool zu irgendeinem Account
nötigen wollen.
So, das ist bestimmt auf Electron-Base. Lasst mal gucken hier.
Wo ist denn überhaupt der Source-Code?
...
Ja.
Source. Moment, wir gucken einfach
in die Package, Jason.
Elektron! Ja.
...
Was sonst?
Wie kann man APIs testen, wenn es ein Offline-Tool
ist? Oder habe ich nicht alles... Naja, dann nicht.
Wenn du aber eine eigene
Software, wenn du was eigenes entwickelst bei dir, startest
das auf dem Entwicklerrechner und willst dann irgendwelche
Tests durchlaufen lassen oder irgendwas ausprobieren,
dann kann das durchaus
sinnvoll sein. Ansonsten,
wenn das Netzwerk
Zugriff braucht und du bist offline, dann
kannst du es natürlich nicht ausprobieren.
Aber was? Also,
diese Tools haben ja viele Möglichkeiten.
Was ich ganz gut finde, du kannst auch beispielsweise
bestimmte Sachen mitschneiden
und dann replayen lassen und sowas.
So, was haben wir ansonsten noch?
AI?
AI? Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Nee, ist es nicht.
Steht übrigens auch noch auf dem Plan, dass wir uns das
näher angucken, aber nicht LazyVim,
sondern NeoVim from
scratch. AI?
IT Tools?
Wie soll das sein?
Hä?
Weiß es nicht.
JavaScript?
BERT?
Witz 2 Backbone with BERT? Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Im Zweifelsfall würde ich mal auf
AI tippen.
Tabby? Okay, ja.
Wenn man unbedingt unter Windows unterwegs sein muss.
Laura?
Haben wir im Stream
auch schon mal ein bisschen mit rumgebastelt.
Local API Testing?
Chat GPT for free?
AI Zeug?
Ja, nicht so spannend
diese Woche, was es gibt.
Today? Was ist denn hier?
Bleeding Edge auf GitHub?
Postgres Driver für Go?
Du ernehmst Autoscaler?
Move it for Rost 2?
Ist das wirklich so?
Ist das Runescape
online oder was ist das?
Was bin ich hier überhaupt sehend?
Ne. Was?
Was ist das?
Robot Software
Component?
Okay, es hat nichts mit Runescape zu tun.
Roboter Framework.
High Performance
Chatbot Framework.
Coggers VLM
Deno?
Ja.
Also diese Woche war nicht so viel Trendendes dabei.
Also was mich interessiert hat.
So, was haben wir denn hier
auf YouTube heute?
Gucken wir uns mal an.
Ne, das wollte ich mir doch angucken.
Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
vom Arbeitsamt.
Was erzählen sie uns denn? Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Was erzählen sie uns denn da drüber?
Das wird was. Dice of Grinch.
Vielleicht taugt es auch.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Initial, ob der Sound richtig stimmt.
Oh, jetzt wird es ein bisschen laut hier.
Aber ich glaube die Lautstärke ist gut.
Also, schauen wir mal.
Drei Minuten vorm Arbeitsamt.
Was gibt es hier?
Also, eins muss ich mal sagen.
Ich habe mir teilweise diese Videos ganz gerne angeguckt.
Und die sind auch
per se nicht schlecht oder so.
Aber ich habe fast den Eindruck,
jedes Video, was ich empfohlen kriege
von Hardware Deals ist mittlerweile nur noch.
Ich habe mir eine Grafikkarte
von AliExpress gekauft.
Ich habe mir ein China CPU gekauft.
Ich habe mir ein China Komplett PC gekauft.
Ich habe mir China aus China importieren lassen.
Ich habe mir ein China aus China importieren lassen.
Gibt es nicht mal was anderes?
Ich verstehe es aber auch.
Das läuft halt gut.
Kann man ja gar nichts dagegen sagen.
Das ist echt immer der gleiche Kram.
Zumindest was mir empfohlen wird.
Vielleicht wird mir auch nur das Zeug empfohlen,
weil es das einzige ist, was ich mal angeklickt habe in letzter Zeit.
Okay, also, was erzählt ihr?
Was machen die da eigentlich gerade?
Okay, er trägt, er trägt Monitore rum.
Das schauen wir mal.
So. Und jetzt stecken sie
ein ganz, ganz kurzes Kabel
in ein Patch Panel rein.
Und dann
haben sie es reingesteckt.
Ratschibas.
Die Ausbildung FachinformatikerIn
für Systemintegration ist abwechslungsreich.
Hier arbeitest du mit Hard- und Software.
Außerdem bist du Problemlöser.
Sollten Kollegen Probleme am Computer haben,
Probleme
gehst du mit Rat und Tat zur Seite.
Nee.
Das ist das Letzte, was ich mache bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Endkunden-Support, Alter.
Nein, nein,
Endkunden ist das falsche Wort.
Wie nennt man das?
User-Support.
Keine zwei Tage
würde ich das machen, ey.
Probleme am Computer haben,
stehst du mit Rat und Tat
zur Seite.
Also, meine Lieblingsfächer und Bestenfächer
in der Schule waren Mathe und
Informatik, was, denke ich mal, logisch ist.
Wir hatten auch Informatik.
Das hieß IT-Systeme bei uns
in der Schule und
wisst ihr, ich glaube, ich habe es schon
500 Mal erzählt. Wisst ihr, was wir
gemacht haben in dem Fach IT-Systeme
bei mir in der Schule? Also, bei mir in der
Schule heißt, das war 2000
rum so.
1999, 98 und so.
98 oder so war das, glaube ich,
das letzte Jahr.
Oder? Ich meine, ich bin 1984
geboren. Das heißt, man kommt eben
mit sieben oder so in der Schule 98.
Oder sowas.
Mit 14, 15,
vielleicht 99, sowas.
Ja, wir haben Office gemacht.
Wir haben fast nur Office gemacht.
Wir hatten einen Lehrer, der hatte
keine Ahnung eigentlich von
Technik. Das einzige, was der konnte,
ist in Word
irgendwelche Briefe schreiben oder Excel.
Wir haben sogar Access benutzt.
Access, Alter. Die
größte Shit-Software aller Zeiten.
Und man hat bei dem
immer eine Eins bekommen, bei dem Lehrer.
Wenn man die
Dokumente lila gefärbt hat.
Das ist kein Witz.
Dann hat er immer, ich weiß,
es ist cringe und ich habe es auch schon fünf Mal erzählt.
Dann hat er immer gesagt, Laila, Laila,
Laila und haben eine Eins gekriegt.
Du musstest
einfach nur das Dokument lila färben.
Es war schon weird champig
alles. Also, zehn Finger
schreiben haben wir dann nicht gelernt, weil das konnte der Kerl
selbst nicht. Ich kann es bis
heute nicht. Leute, Frage,
wer von euch kann
blind zehn Finger
schreiben?
Zwei Leute, drei Leute,
vier Leute, fünf.
Okay, also wir haben ein paar,
die das können und
okay, jetzt machen wir das andere
das andere Extrem.
Wer von euch, aber das dürften wahrscheinlich
die wenigsten, dürften wahrscheinlich die wenigsten sein.
Wer von euch
macht noch zwei Finger
Adlersuchsystem?
Wahrscheinlich keiner,
aber wirklich.
Also Leute, die sich das jagen,
eher nicht.
Also zwei Finger, es ist ja so
Ich glaube, die meisten
hier werden das ähnlich
machen wie ich.
So ein eigenes
sagen wir mal
fünf bis acht
Finger
Blindtippsystem.
Ich habe da, ich habe kein System,
was man irgendwie System nennen
könnte, aber
ich meine, hallo, Kekkel,
Chat, das habe ich jetzt blind geschrieben
zum Beispiel. Das ist so ein
ja, eine
Mischung aus Finger,
wo ich denke, dass es
irgendwie hin muss und
und auch nicht immer die gleichen Finger
als System kann man das nicht nennen.
Ja, ja,
so mache ich das auch, also ich tippe
und ich gucke auch, ich gucke auch ganz gerne
mal immer wieder zwischendurch
KekW so auf die Tastatur.
Weiß nicht, also
ich habe da so ein eigenes, so ein eigenes
Ding, ja. Letztendlich
so die Standard Linux
Dinger, also ich kann die meisten Sachen
eigentlich blind treffen, aber ich gucke trotzdem
beim Überlegen immer mal wieder auf die
Tastatur, also
ich finde so eine super krasse,
auch wenn das teilweise in Videos angepriesen wird,
so, gibt ja immer so Videos
wie How-to-Productivity-Tipps und sowas.
Ich muss sagen, so die super krasse
Produktivitätssteigerung zu einem richtig
echten 10 Finger
blind tippen, glaube ich
gar nicht mal, weil 10 Finger blind tippen
reicht ja gar nicht. Man müsste ja 10 Finger
blind inklusive allen Sonderzeichen tippen
können. Da wird es halt schon ein bisschen schwieriger.
Ja, ja, das denke
ich mir auch. Ich kann aus, ich kann aus allen
Haltungen und Lagen
hier irgendwelche Sachen ein, ups.
Ja, nice Chat.
LSLA hinten dran. Beste.
Popout
gleich LS minus LA.
Ja, also ich sehe, ihr macht es wahrscheinlich,
ihr macht es wahrscheinlich ähnlich.
Ich finde auch nicht,
dass es wirklich notwendig ist, weil die
meiste Zeit ist man eh am Überlegen
und
ja, am
Nachdenken halt, ja.
So, also schauen wir mal weiter, schauen wir mal weiter.
Okay, wo sind wir, wo sind wir?
Schule war Mathe
und Informatik, was, denke ich mal, logisch ist.
Boah, ich kenne genug, die nicht
gut in Mathe waren.
Aber auch Englisch ist sehr wichtig, weil sehr viele
Anleitungen. Das stimmt. Oder Sachen, die man
recherchieren muss. Das stimmt. Ich muss, ich muss sagen,
ich war nie sonderlich gut in Englisch in der
Schule. Das lag aber auch daran, weil
mir die Lehrer auf den Sack gegangen sind. Ich kann bockern.
Mittlerweile,
we are all sitting in one boat.
Mittlerweile geht es eigentlich.
Mir fehlt, mir fehlt schlicht und ergreifend ein bisschen
die Praxis, was das speaking
angeht. Aber
so das, also
ich meine, ich gucke die meisten Filme und Sachen
auch nur noch in Englisch und lese quasi
zu 90 Prozent englische Webseiten.
Also da kommt man durch ohne Probleme
mittlerweile. Das Reden
ist Übungssache. Ich muss auf der Arbeit
mittlerweile öfters, öfters Englisch reden,
weil wir haben einen Spanier
bei uns im Team, im erweiterten
Team haben wir einen Spanier
und nachdem ich kein Spanisch kann und der kein
Deutsch kann, reden wir Englisch und das geht eigentlich ganz
gut. Solange sich das,
solange sich das um technische Themen dreht, überhaupt
kein Ding. Und bisschen, bisschen
Balltalk drum herum geht auch.
Ich meine, ich könnte jetzt sicherlich nicht
irgendwelche
mittelalterlichen
philosophischen englischen Texte
lesen oder so. Da würde ich
aufgeschmissen. Aber ganz im Ernst, selbst
die meisten Native Speaker
in Deutsch
sind, also Muttersprachler
könnte man sagen,
haben Probleme, ältere
deutsche Texte ordentlich zu lesen.
Also das würde ich mir jetzt da keine Gedanken drum
machen. Und klar, ne, also
aus irgendwelchen anderen Fachgebieten
habe ich auf Englisch auch keine Ahnung.
Aber Alltagssachen und so
würde ich da
denke, also ich müsste dort nicht verhungern
und ich könnte da
mich auch durchmogeln.
Das wird schon funktionieren.
Mir fehlt also die
Sprechübung, weil außer
mit unserem Spanier
und das übliche Denglisch,
was ich hier fabriziere,
habe ich halt nichts.
Ja, ich kann mich auf der Gamescom erinnern, auf der Gamescom
war es auch immer so, so der erste halbe
Tag bis Tag war immer ein bisschen gestotter,
aber danach ging's.
Englisch-Stream, oh ja, ganz bestimmt.
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet,
dass wir Englisch-Stream machen.
...und nicht übersetzt sind.
Das denkst du mir.
Okay, jetzt habe ich nicht zugehört. Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ich muss jetzt mal das Video laufen lassen.
Keckels und lull wehst du eigentlich auch
real life, ja? Ich habe doch gestern
mal mit der GoPro
ein Video aufgenommen,
wie ich Fahrrad gefahren bin.
Und dazwischen drin
habe ich mal für euch
ein bisschen gelabert im Hintergrund.
Also wir haben uns gestern nur zwei, drei Minuten Ausschnitt
daraus ausgeguckt und wir gucken uns das auch
nicht komplett an, das war nur so ein Aufnahmetest.
Und ich habe im Hintergrund ein bisschen gelabert
und ich habe allen Ernstes, während ich
Fahrradfahren war,
mehrfach gesagt, Monka Stier,
lull weh
und Keckel bestimmt auch.
Also ich rede,
ich rede auch normal so anscheinend.
...
Jetzt überlegt euch mal,
ihr lauft an irgendeinem
vorbei und er kommt euch mit dem
Fahrrad entgegen und ihr hört von dem
beim Fahrradfahren Monka Stier.
Gut, die meisten Leute werden es nicht checken,
die denken halt, der telefoniert gerade
und labert dummes Zeug vor sich hin.
Und wird es so keck wehen.
Ja, ich auch.
Also wenn ihr mal irgendeinen auf einem blauen Fahrrad
rumfahren seht, in der Nähe
von Frankfurt, der Monka Stier
sagt beim Fahren, dann bin ich das wahrscheinlich.
Okay, also wir gucken jetzt echt das Video
fertig.
Ist das ein Raspberry Pi?
Nee, ist es nicht.
Ist ein Dell
Optiplex Microservice
Manual
Handbuch.
Sehr wichtig, weil sehr viele Anleitungen
oder Sachen, die man recherchieren muss im Internet,
einfach auf Englisch sind und nicht übersetzt sind.
Und es ist auch gut so,
es ist auch gut so, dass das nicht übersetzt ist.
Ich meine ernsthaft, hier, machen wir mal
keine Ahnung.
So.
Alter, die Microsoft
Seite ist so kacke. Ich finde den Knopf noch nicht mal.
Das hat doch so einen Translation Knopf immer oben gehabt.
Wo ist denn der hin? Ist der weg?
Microsoft Seite, die macht mich so fertig.
In der Uhr. Nee,
es gibt auf der Microsoft Seite
gibt es doch immer hier so Knöpfe neben, wo man das
translaten kann. Warum ist denn das jetzt weg?
Ich meine, das geht auch.
Ja, maschinell übersetzt.
Ich meine, guckt euch das an, wenn man sich
das hier teilweise durchliest.
Man will das einfach nicht auf Deutsch
lesen, ja. Es ist gut, dass
es nicht übersetzt wird.
Man will das
gar nicht auf Deutsch lesen oftmals.
Ja. Zumal man halt
auch nichts findet, wenn man nach Fehlern sucht auf Deutsch.
Glaube ich nicht.
Technisches Verständnis.
Das ist immer etwas verkehrt.
Ausdrucksvermögen. Lernbereitschaft.
Ja, das könnte man sagen.
Das trifft auf nahezu jeden halbwegs
Kundenorientierung
und Ausdrucksvermögen.
Also Kunden, je nachdem, was man als Kunde
definiert,
gehen mir eher auf den Keks, anstatt
dass ich da sonderlich
orientiert bin. Also wenn man jetzt
irgendwelche Endanwender meint, die
mich fragen würden,
wie
stelle ich in Excel das und das
ein, dann wäre ich nicht sonderlich.
Aber das wäre auch nicht der richtige Job für mich.
Leute, Excel-Kenner unter euch,
wie kann ich in Excel,
ich drehe nämlich immer durch,
wenn ich Office Shit verwenden muss,
wie kann ich in Excel
alle
Wörter, also wenn ich jetzt
nach dem Wort kekwe suche
in der Excel-Tabelle, wie kann ich
alle Vorkommnisse des Wortes
kekwe highlighten lassen?
Beziehungsweise
wenigstens zu der Zelle springen,
wo kekwe drinnen steht. Aktuell,
wenn ich in Excel nach kekwe suche,
dann highlightet er mir jede Zeile,
wo irgendwo in der Zeile kekwe
vorkommt. Das ist richtig
dämlich. Kannst du überhaupt nichts
suchen drin. Ja, der durchsucht
die ganze Mappe, aber der durchsucht jede Zeile,
wo kekwe drinnen kommt. Ich will die Zelle
haben. Kann man nicht einstellen.
Zumindest nicht da, wo
in dem normalen Search-Dialog.
Also bin ich,
jetzt lassen wir das Video durchlaufen.
In der Praxis
stellen Betriebe daher oft Auszubildende
mit Hochschulreife oder mittlerer Reife
ein. Ja. Die Ausbildung selbst
dauert dann drei Jahre im dualen System.
Du wechselst also zum Spieler.
Ist das ein virtuelles
Teams-Klassen-Treffen, oder?
Ausbildungsbetrieb und Berufsschule.
Also quasi, ja, keine Ahnung.
Also wenn du zuhause derjenige bist,
der den Drucker installieren oder das Handy installieren
muss, dann bist du für die Ausbildung
zum Fachinformatiker mit Systemintegration
genau richtig. Drucker. Das lernst du.
Den Aufbau und die Installation
von Hard- und Software, das
Programmieren und Coden, Kundenumgang
im Anwendersupport.
Hör mal auf. Das würde mich jetzt
abschrecken. Alter, ich würde
im Leben nicht diese Ausbildung anfangen
mit dieser Beschreibung, Mann.
Kundensupport,
Kundenumgang im Anwendersupport,
Drucker installieren.
Wenn das, hätten
die mir das angekündigt damals,
hätte ich im Leben nicht diese Ausbildung
gemacht.
Glücklicherweise habe ich mit
Kundensupport und Drucker auch nichts zu tun.
Also in dem Beruf hat man regelmäßig
Kontakt zu anderen Menschen, da man
wirklich tatsächlich die betreuen
muss in ihren IT-Problemen, in ihren
täglichen IT-Problemen.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das schwebt vielleicht der IHK
oder dem Arbeitsamt vor. Das ist ganz
entscheidend davon abhängig, wo
in welcher Firma und in welchem
Team, in welcher Position, wo man seine Ausbildung
macht. Ich würde sogar
sagen, die wenigsten
machen reinen Druckerwechsel
Support.
Vielleicht bin ich da auch ein bisschen
vorbelastet. Ich habe ja die Ausbildung
damals bei einem Internetprovider gemacht
und da war mit Endkunden nichts für uns.
Und ich hatte nie großartig Endkundenkontakt.
Aber Endkundenkontakt, das ist das
nervigste und schlimmste, was ich mir täglich
vorstellen könnte. Den Job würde ich nicht
lange machen. Ich habe hier eine ganze
Weile in der Nähe von unserem Support
gehockt, in einer alten Firma.
Und das war kein reiner, das heißt
kein reiner, das war kein Endkundensupport.
Also da hat nicht irgendjemand angerufen
und hat gesagt, hier beim Login kommt ein Fehler oder so was.
Da riefen interne Leute
halt an bei
bei Problemen
mit irgendwelchen Services, wo dann
nachgeguckt wurde, ah guck mal hier,
Service ist auch gerade irgendwie
im Monitoring down oder was auch immer.
Und das, was ich da schon mitbekommen
habe, ging mir schon immer auf den Sack.
Und das war kein richtiger Endkundensupport.
Das war nochmal eine Nummer
besser und das war schon übelst nervig.
Also mein einziger
längerer
Kontakt kann man nicht sagen.
Kontakt mit Endkunden war
mal, wo ich eine fehlgeleitete
E-Mail bekommen habe.
Unser System geht nicht.
Und die E-Mail war falsch.
Die war eindeutig falsch bei uns.
Und ich habe mich dazu
erbarmt
auf diese E-Mail zu antworten
und habe ihr geschrieben,
sie ist bei uns falsch, aber wenn sie
mir sagt, um
welches System es geht,
dann kann ich die Anfrage vielleicht
weiterleiten an jemand,
der sich damit auskennt.
Und ihre Antwort war nur noch,
ich meine das System, mit dem wir täglich
arbeiten, 500 Ausrufezeichen.
Und dann
hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
Da habe ich einfach gedacht,
viel Spaß.
Eine ultra bescheuerte Antwort, oder?
Was weiß ich?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das ist.
Deswegen ist es wichtig,
dass man da auch ein bisschen empathisch und geduldig
an das Thema angeht.
Laptop geht aus.
Neue Maus und Headsets.
Schutzglas, Handy defekt.
Tabulator bleibt stehen.
Friert ein.
Ey, das würde ich keine zwei Tage aushalten.
Das wäre echt der blanke Horror.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
anscheinend haben die nicht allzu viel zu tun,
wenn innerhalb von ein paar Tagen das das einzige ist.
Da hätte ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
Dark Zone, das passt einfach.
Die Leute sind teilweise richtig planlos.
Also,
ich meine,
nichts gegen Leute,
denen das Spaß macht.
Es gibt bestimmt Leute,
die finden da ihre Erfüllung drin,
IT-Support zu machen.
Es mag auch seine
schönen Seiten haben,
wenn du Leute hast, die sich dann freuen,
wenn es funktioniert und alles.
Aber ich würde es keine zwei Tage aushalten.
Ja, Wurzelser, Problembeschreibungen
sind auch mal oft so ein Ding.
Manchmal liegt es daran,
dass die Leute die Hälfte skippen
oder selbst nicht wissen, was Sache ist.
Man hat einfach so viele verschiedene Sachen,
die auf einen zukommen.
Vor allem, wenn man dann in die Richtung von Support geht,
was man da hat.
Dann kommen einfach ganz verschiedene Fälle immer,
weil jeder andere Mitarbeiter oder Kunde,
mit dem man da zu tun hat,
hat sein ganz eigenes Problem, an das man sich dann ransetzt
und das versucht zu lösen.
Aber ein bisschen
schrauben würde ich schon ab und zu mal gerne machen.
Mache ich halt gar nicht mehr.
Ich meine,
wann war ich das letzte Mal im Rechenzentrum?
Ewig her.
Ich überlege gerade,
wann war ich das letzte Mal in einem Rechenzentrum?
Bestimmt ein Jahr, locker.
Locker ein Jahr her.
Kann mich jetzt gar nicht daran erinnern.
So ändern sich die Zeiten.
Von täglich durch mehrere Serverräume
laufen zu
irgendwann vor einem Jahr vielleicht.
... jedes Unternehmen oder Behörden,
Computer oder Programme.
Also in der Ausbildung lernt man die komplette
Netzwerkinfrastruktur aufzubauen.
Alle Hardwarekomponenten
lernt man kennen.
Nicht einfach Hardware,
alle Leute, alle Hardwarekomponenten.
... behalten.
Sie können Software verteilen
auf alle Clients, auf alle Rechner.
So lange es Windows ist wahrscheinlich.
... einer Meister- oder Technikerprüfung
zum Beispiel im Bereich...
Niemand juckt das doch, Alter!
Juckt irgendjemand
wirklich die weiterführenden
Physi aus? Also es gibt ja, wenn du Physi
gelernt hast, kannst du bei der IHK ja noch...
Da gibt es ja noch so Weiterführungsdinger.
Gibt es irgendjemand, den das juckt?
... technische Informatik
oder ein Studium an einer
Fachhochschule, zum Beispiel
Informationstechnik. Vielleicht schon.
Ich habe noch nicht einen gesehen, bis jetzt zumindest.
... die Schnittstelle zwischen Technik und Anwender.
Wenn du gerne anderen bei Problemen hilfst,
Freude an Technik und Tüfteln hast,
dann bist du hier richtig. Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt.
Freude an Technik und Basteln ist natürlich
sinnvoll.
... ist ein gefragter Beruf mit Perspektive.
Ja, das stimmt auch.
Die Vorstellung von dem
Beruf hätte mich jetzt halt komplett abgeschreckt,
ihn zu machen. Weil wenn eines der
Kernsachen Endkundensupport oder generell
Support ist, da wäre es
bei mir halt schon vorbei gewesen.
Da muss man sich so viel mit
anderen Menschen auseinandersetzen, da kriegst
du ja Zustände.
Also mit nicht technikinteressierten
anderen Menschen.
Da triffst du ja
am Rad.
Was verdient ein Tennistrainer?
Wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Solange er Leute hat.
Also pro Stunde gut,
aber er wird nicht den ganzen Tag trainern.
Was haben wir
das nächste? MetaQuest 3 im Test.
MetaQuest?
Ist das der Nachfolger von
Oculus?
Weil Facebook, also Meta hat ja
das gekauft damals.
Ich blicke bei den Produktbezeichnungen
da nicht mehr durch.
Zumindest hat die erste Oculus Rift
vor so 5-6 Jahren
diesen riesen neuen VR-Hype ausgelöst.
Und das ist schon
länger her, wahrscheinlich eher 7-8 Jahre.
Wo dann alle gesagt haben, ja jetzt
endlich VR, jetzt Durchbruch.
Aber nein, war es halt auch nicht.
Updatet sich der Chromium
bei dir immer selbst?
Das zeigt ja einen Update-Dialog an.
Ob ich upgraden will oder nicht.
Aber ne, überwinden geht nicht.
Ja, ich glaube das ist schon wieder so
lange her mit den VR-Brillen.
Man kann sich das ganz einfach überlegen.
War es vor Corona? Ja.
Das heißt, es ist schon mal
3-4 Jahre her.
War es aktuell auf
einer der Gamescoms, wo ich zuletzt gewesen bin?
Ja, das ist auch schon ein paar
Jahre her. Also insofern
muss das 6-7 Jahre her sein,
wo dieser VR-Hype war.
Genau, und der Hype
ist schon wieder vorbei.
Das heißt, es muss eine Weile her gewesen sein.
Welche Windows-Packager,
wenn überhaupt tatsächlich Win geht, aber das
meiste wird installiert und dann halt mit dem
jeweiligen Updater, die fast jede Software
mitbringt, geupdatet. Wo wir gerade
dabei sind. Ich glaube, ich muss VLC updaten.
Nein, muss ich nicht. Ich habe gestern schon geupdatet.
Ok.
Guck mal hier, so sieht unser Konferenzraum
aus, wenn ich durch die neue
MetaQuest 3 durchgucke.
Das meiste ist echt, aber das Loch, das
in der Decke, das ist natürlich Computer-Grafik.
Das hätte ich jetzt gedacht, das ist auch echt.
Guck mal hier, so sieht unser
Konferenzraum aus, wenn ich durch die neue
MetaQuest 3 durchgucke.
Das meiste ist echt, aber das Loch
da in der Decke, das ist natürlich Computer-Grafik.
Ja gut, und auch die Monster hier.
Wenn ich das will, kann ich aber auch nahtlos
zwischen meiner echten Umgebung und einer
komplett künstlichen VR-Welt umschalten.
Das sieht ziemlich cool aus. Und wenn ihr
jetzt denkt, hä, ist das nicht genau wie bei der
Apple Vision Pro? Ja, da habt ihr recht.
Nur, dass die Quest 3 statt
bei 100€ halt nur 550€
kostet. Also die Apple Vision,
das wird irgendwann in ein paar Jahren vielleicht mal
interessant, wenn es dafür ordentliche
Anwendungsgebiete gibt. Das jetzt ist
eher was für
Bastler und Entwickler.
Die MetaQuest 3 ausführlich getestet
und zeigen euch, wo die Unterschiede
zur Apple-Brille liegen. Sieht ein bisschen
aus wie das Ding, was Sam Fisher
früher auf hatte. Aber natürlich auch
wie die Quest 3 im Vergleich zu günstigeren
Headsets wie der Quest 2 oder der Sony
PSVR 2 abschneidet.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerinnen, liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier
bei
...
Dieses Video wird gesponsert
von HP. Stellt euch mal vor,
ihr sitzt an eurem Schreibtisch und arbeitet
an einem super wichtigen ... Okay, das war ein Sponsor,
den sieht man nicht oft. ... an eurem
Schreibtisch, sondern im Hotel zum Beispiel.
Und plötzlich schwarzer Bildschirm, nichts geht
mehr. Panikanfall? Nein.
Denn wenn euer Laptop das HP
Care Pack hat, dann kriegt ihr drei Jahre
Vor-Ort-Service und telefonischen
Support. Statt jetzt lange zu googeln, wo das
Problem liegen könnte, ruft ihr einfach mal ein.
Doch, doch, die aktuelle 3D-Brille oder die aktuelle
VR, AR, was auch immer Brille ist eindeutig
für Entwickler und Bastler. Da ist noch
nix für Endkunde gedacht.
Das kommt erst noch.
Falls da was Gescheites bei rauskommt.
Einer dedizierten Support-Hotline
an ... Was hältst du von HP-Druckern?
Ich würde nicht so unbedingt nach dem
Hersteller gehen. Ich halte prinzipiell
von allen Druckern nichts,
die noch Tintenstrahldrucker sind.
Oder Tintenstrahldrucker.
Egal welche Hersteller. Tintenstrahldrucker
sind einfach abfuck größter
Shit ever.
Laserdrucker vollkommen okay.
Egal von welchem Hersteller.
Am besten ist natürlich, wenn man
ein Farblaser-Multifunktions-Ding hat,
dann hat man ausgesorgt für die nächsten
Jahrzehnte. HP ...
Generell, seriously, alle
Tintendrucker, das ist
alles Schrott.
Alles übertrieben
Schrott. Man braucht eine
monatliche Subscription, darum man
drucken darf. Dann würde ich es einfach nicht kaufen.
Also ich habe mir vor einer Weile einen
Brother
Farblaser-Multifunktions-Ding
gekauft. Ich habe vergessen, wie das
heißt. Die Dinger haben ja auch übelst bescheuerte Namen
immer. Und seitdem ich den habe,
keine Probleme. Ich drucke selten,
aber wenn ich drucken muss, dann halt auch meistens
mal irgendwie 20 Seiten oder so. Und das
war beim Tintenstrahldrucker immer
absoluter
ultra mega abfuck.
Weil wenn du nur ein paar Mal im Jahr druckst,
musst du danach erstmal Düsenreinigung machen,
dann funktioniert es wieder nicht richtig.
Richtig scheiße.
Und jetzt
Laserdrucker vom Tablet
Air...ne, nicht Airplay.
Wie heißt das? Airprint war das.
Dings, drucken, zack.
Es war anscheinend ausgedruckt.
Fertig.
Du druckst da wahrscheinlich auch...
Wenn das Tinte ist,
dann druckst du wahrscheinlich auch öfters als 1-2 Mal im Jahr.
Also ich kaufe doch
kein Abo, um mit meinem gekauften Drucker
zu drucken. Also ich spinne. Ja.
Brotherding ist wirklich ganz nice.
Leider haben die Dinger wieder
komplett wirre Produktbezeichnung.
Nämlich
obviously heißt das Ding
wenn ich gekauft habe, Moment.
Es heißt
ähm
Ja, wenn jetzt da der Produktname noch irgendwie dabei
stehen würde. Hier.
MFC, so heißen die
Brotherdinger ja alle,
L3750
CDW
Alles klar?
Ich finde es ist
komplett obviously was
dieser Produktname
meint.
MFC L3750 CDW
Ganz klar.
Ich glaube das einzige was ich
erkenne ist, W ist Wireless.
Color
Ah, Duplex.
Ok, wenn man es weiß ergibt es sogar
Sinn, aber griffig ist was anderes.
Laser
L3750, warum auch immer.
Ja.
Ein OCR-Scan. Keine Ahnung ob das
OCR-Scan hat. Juckt mich auch nicht ob das
OCR-Scan hat. Wenn ich OCR brauche
dann scanne ich es und mache OCR mit
irgendeiner eigenen Software dafür.
Ja, das Ding hier.
Das ist zwar ein bisschen größer und vielleicht übelst
overkill für jemand der nicht oft druckt, aber
es funktioniert einfach.
Und da wisst ihr was das beste ist?
Was man in Deutschland
ja immer noch ab und zu braucht.
Es hat ein Fax.
Man kann damit Faxe schicken
wenn man will. Guckt, er druckt
er kopiert, er scannt und er
faxt.
Aber er kann nicht faxen bei mir
weil ich kein Telefonkabel
eingesteckt habe. Ich habe auch nicht vor
ein Telefonkabel einzustecken.
Aber ich könnte ein Telefonkabel einstecken
wenn ich will. Da werden Faxen
gemacht. Ich schicke keine Faxe
mehr und wenn, würde ich gar keinen Fax
damit schicken, sondern über irgendeinen Webservice.
Aber immerhin, man könnte
Faxe schicken und dementsprechend ist er auch
Deutschlandbehörden ready.
Chatke
Mich hat gar keiner ans Trinken
erinnert in letzter Zeit. Das ist schlecht.
Jetzt habe ich ganz rauen Hals. Ich muss noch was trinken.
Faxe denn wirklich noch jemand?
Ja. In Deutschland
ist Fax immer noch recht beliebt.
Guckt mal bei irgendwelchen Behörden. War es nicht
sogar so, dass am Anfang, Anfang von
Corona, die Zahlen noch
per Post übermittelt wurden oder per Fax?
Und wenn das Fax samstags eingetroffen
ist, war keiner da, der es lesen konnte und
so komische Dinger. Also mich würde das
nicht wundern, wenn es heute immer noch so
wäre, dass viele Faxen
machen. Indirekt gibt es das
ja schon.
Du kannst heute Faxe schicken
über deinen Telefonanschluss,
der eigentlich nur noch ein VoIP-Anschluss
ist.
Also Fax
ist in
Deutschland immer noch angesagt.
8-17 Uhr für euch da, auch aus dem
Ausland und die versuchen dann zuerst remote
das Problem mit euch zu lösen, sollte das
nicht klappen, kommt ein von HP
autorisierter Techniker oder Technikerin
zu euch, die das Gerät entweder mit einem
Ersatzteil reparieren oder gleich ganz
austauschen. Laut HP können in der Regel
80% der Probleme spätestens
am nächsten Werktag gelöst werden.
Heißt, ihr müsst das Gerät nicht irgendwo
hinschicken. Wisst ihr, was geil wäre? Wenn die
Notebook ausliefern würden, dass es durch Laufen
kaputt geht. Das wäre auch
erst mal warten, sondern es kommt garantiert
jemand zu euch mit der Lösung.
Klingt gut, oder? Ja, das HP Care Pack
ist Teil des HP Hardware Services
im Security Bundle und direkt
beim Kauf von ausgewählten HP
Rechnern dabei. Ganz ohne Aufpreis.
Mehr dazu in der Videobeschreibung.
Ob das so ein Verkaufsargument ist?
Ich bin ja schon seit Jahren so ein VR-Typ.
Ich gar nicht.
Mir kommt das auf, dass ich mich für VR
interessiere. Deshalb ist die Quest 3 für
mich eine echt große Sache, weil
der Vorgänger Quest 2 mit ziemlichem
Abstand das meistverkaufte
VR-Headset aller Zeiten ist.
Er geht von fast 20 Millionen verkauften
Stück aus. Anders als PC-Headsets
wie der Valve Index oder der PlayStation
VR 2, muss man keinen PC
oder Konsole an Quest-Headsets
anschließen. Die laufen komplett autark.
Da ist ein Android-System integriert. Man kann
also einfach in irgendeinen Raum gehen und kurz
mal in die virtuelle Realität springen, ohne
über irgendwelche Kabel nachzudenken.
Ihr könnt die Quest 3 aber auch...
Wireless ist natürlich nice. Also das
erste Mal, wo ich VR auf der Gamescom
ausprobiert habe, war das alles noch mit Kabel.
Und da ist permanent einer hinter dir hergelaufen,
der hat die Kabel so getragen, dass du nicht drüberfällst.
...dekoppeln. Das geht einfach mit einem
USB-Kabel oder sogar über WLAN.
Dann könnt ihr grafisch aufwendigere
PC-Spiele spielen. Ziemlich praktisch.
Allerdings ist die Nachfrage nach Quest-Headsets
stark eingebrochen. Offenbar hat
Meta doll von der Pandemie
profitiert. Naja. Aber nun gibt's ja neue
Hardware. Meta hat uns vor Verkaufsstart
ein Quest 3-Testgerät zur Verfügung gestellt.
Wir haben aber auch selbst noch eins gekauft.
Seit dem 10. Oktober werden die
Headsets ausgeliefert. Die 128 GB
Version kostet 550 Euro.
Die 512er Version
700 Euro. Das ist ein steiler
Preissprung. Die Quest 2 gibt's
ja mit 128... Okay, ja, das ist ein
steiler Preissprung. Man muss aber sagen,
das ist immer noch ein verhältnismäßig
niedriger Preissprung. Vergleicht
mal das kleine
iPhone 14, 15 mit
dem 512G iPhone 14, 15.
Da ist kein Preissprung
von 100, 150 Euro. Das sind eher
keine Ahnung, wie viel?
300, 400 Euro?
Für...
Wenn du überlegst, heute kriegst du eine halbwegs
schnelle Micro-SD-Karte schon
für... in der Größe schon
für 40 Euro.
Okay, da wird vielleicht noch ein bisschen was besseres drin sein,
aber trotzdem.
Also die Speicherpreise sind hyperpipiger
bei Smartphones. 700 Euro.
Das ist ein steiler Preissprung.
Die Quest 2 gibt's ja mit 128
GB für 350 Euro
schon. Was kriegt man also für die
200 Euro Aufpreis? Ich hab euch mal
drei Verbesserungen hier zusammengestellt.
Verbesserung Nummer 1.
Path-Through Mixed Reality.
Der wohl auffälligste Unterschied ist die sogenannte
Path-Through-Funktion, die
die Umgebung per Kamera einfängt und
in quasi Echtzeit
im Headset anzeigt. Das Bild kann dann
mit künstlichen Bildelementen angereichert
werden, also Augmented Reality oder
wie man heute meist sagt, Mixed Reality.
Ja, ich such den Sinn auch noch ein bisschen.
Ich mein für Games
ja, nice, aber es gibt nicht so
viele VR-Games.
Also Half-Life Alyx ist das einzige
Game, wo ich sagen würd, ey, da hätt ich richtig Bock drauf.
Vielleicht noch Resident Evil,
das VR Resident Evil.
Ansonsten gibt's da nicht so viel.
Und für diese ganze
Mixed Reality Geschichte hab ich persönlich
gar keinen Anwendungszweck.
Okay,
seriously, wir wissen alle und ihr
wisst es auch, wofür
VR am meisten verwendet wird.
Es ist nicht Games, es ist nicht Mixed Reality,
sondern es ist, korrekt,
...
wie viele andere neue Technologien auch,
ist VR natürlich
in diesem Segment am allerbeliebtesten.
Man kann es auch kombinieren mit beliebigen
Sachen, okay, ja.
Aber da ist VR tatsächlich schon
angekommen und das ist
nicht jetzt verwunderlich,
weil wenn man sich mal
in die Vergangenheit guckt, was
Videos und DVDs
und solche Geschichten,
ich glaub wahrscheinlich auch die ersten,
bei Blu-Ray weiß ich nicht, aber die ersten Anfänge
anguckt,
eines der ersten Branchen, die
da aufgesprungen sind und da mitgemacht haben,
waren irgendwelche Porns.
Und dementsprechend,
ja, war das bei VR auch klar,
dass das dafür sofort
am Start ist.
Das ganze klappt mit diesen beiden RGB
Kameras hier und dem tiefen
Sensor in der Mitte. Im besten Fall sollte
man nicht merken, dass man ein Headset auf hat,
wenn man sich umguckt, aber in der Realität
fällt es dann doch deutlich auf.
Das Bild sieht etwas künstlich aus,
etwas pixelig und manchmal wobbelt es
auch ein bisschen. Aber ganz klar,
das Path-Through-Bild ist deutlich besser
als bei Quest 2, Quest Pro,
Pico 4 und PlayStation VR 2.
Hier mal zum Vergleich der gleiche Raum
mit der Quest 2, der Quest Pro
und der Quest 3.
Meta gibt keine konkreten Spezifikationen
an, sagt aber, dass das
Path-Through-Bild eine doppelt so hohe Auflösung
hat wie bei der Quest Pro und
eine zehnmal so hohe wie bei der Quest 2.
Außerdem ist das Bild farbig,
bei der Quest 2 war es noch schwarz-weiß.
Ich muss sagen, dass das Path-Through für mich
wirklich eine ganz neue Erfahrung war,
denn zum ersten Mal konnte ich mit einem aufgesetzten
Headset Text auf Displays ablesen,
also auf Computer, Monitor oder Smartphone.
Das ist im Alltag super praktisch,
wenn man manchmal schon irgendwas nachgucken will
und man dafür nicht das Headset absetzt.
Die große Frage allerdings ist,
wie schneidet die Quest 3 im Vergleich
zu Apples Vision Pro ab?
Leider konnte ich die Apple-Brille noch nicht
selbst ausprobieren, Kollegen von mir aber schon
und Apple macht das Path-Through
offenbar noch einmal besser als Meta
aber auch bei Apple vergisst man laut Aussagen
von Testern nie,
dass man ein Headset auf hat.
Das dauert wohl noch ein paar Jährchen.
Ja und was kann man damit nun machen mit diesem Path-Through?
Ja, ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so viel.
Es gibt bislang erst wenige Apps,
die das unterstützen. Eine sehr schöne ist
von Meta selbst, die ist kostenlos,
heißt First Encounters und da kommen dann
so neckische Aliens aus der Decke.
Was ich ziemlich beeindruckend fand,
das System hat die Lampen in diesem Raum hier erkannt,
das heißt, dass die echten Lampen
das künstliche Loch verdeckt haben.
Besonders cool, einige dieser künstlichen
Brocken sind sogar auf die Lampe
gefallen, statt direkt auf den Boden.
Ziemlich nice.
Ansonsten könnt ihr Browserfenster, Videofenster
etc. in eurer echten Umgebung
frei anordnen, also so ziemlich
genau das, was Apple auch
bei den Vision Pro Demos gezeigt hat.
Ich stehe deshalb auch zu 100%
zu meiner Aussage, dass Quest 3
und Apple Vision Pro exakt
die gleiche Produktkategorie sind.
Die beherrschen die gleichen Funktionen
auch wenn viele Leute sagen, dass Apple
ja nun was ganz anderes erfunden hat.
Es ist aber einfach nur so, dass Apple
weniger auf Spiele setzt und mehr auf
Produktivität, aber es wird für
die Vision Pro auch Spiele geben und für die
Quest Headsets gibt es ja jetzt sogar schon
Arbeitstools wie Virtual Desktop
oder Horizon Workrooms.
Ich bezweifle allerdings stark, also stand
Können die denn auch Wobbly Windows?
Weil ohne Wobbly Windows ist
das ja alles nix. Heute, dass
viele Menschen den ganzen Arbeitstag
so ein schweres Headset auf dem Kopf haben
das gilt sowohl für die Quest 3 als auch
für die Vision Pro. Meine Erfahrung ist,
eine Stunde am Tag fühlt sich für mich gut an,
alles was länger ist, ja, Kopfschmerzen.
Ich bin aber wirklich gespannt, wie das
weitergeht, vielleicht täusche ich mich auch.
Achso, was aber halt wirklich auch ohne jegliche
Apps praktisch ist, dass man mit der
Quest 3 auch in 100% VR
Welten mit einem Doppeltipp aufs Gehäuse
mal kurz die echte Welt einblenden kann.
Weil man zum Beispiel was trinken will
oder kurz mal nach der Katze gucken.
Verbesserung Nummer 2, optische
Qualität, Linsen und Disney.
Ganz klar, dass die Quest 3 bessere
Linsen hat als die Quest 2, das sieht
man instantan, wenn man das Teil aufsetzt.
Statt dicken Fresnel Linsen sind da nun
flache sogenannte Pancake Linsen drin.
Der große Vorteil, die sind immer
scharf, man muss also nicht wie bei der Quest 2
und ganz schlimm bei der Playstation VR 2
die genau in der richtigen Position
vor den Augen haben. Ich hab davon halt
gar keine Ahnung, ich hab
ich hab kein VR Headset.
Nachteil von Pancake ist, dass
die Linsen mehr Licht schlucken, aber das ist
meines Erachtens bei der Quest 3 kein Problem.
Ich empfand das Bild immer als hell genug.
Durch die Pancake Linsen fällt die
Quest 3 deutlich kleiner aus als
die Quest 2. Das kann man sehr schön sehen, wenn man
das Gesichtspolster da mal abnimmt.
Leichter ist sie aber leider nicht.
Beide Headsets wiegen ungefähr ein halbes Kilo.
Was ebenfalls schnell auffällt,
die Auflösung ist ein ganzes Stück höher.
Pro Auge 2064
mal 2208 Pixel
statt wie bei der Quest 2
1832 mal 1920.
Die PSVR 2 hat auch
weniger als die Quest 3, nämlich
2000 mal 2040.
Apples Vision Pro ist aber nochmal eine ganz andere
Sportart, die zeigt jedem Auge mehr als
doppelt so viele Pixel.
Die Quest 3 hat allerdings nur LC Displays,
das heißt schwarz ist eher dunkelgrau
und auch die Farben kommen nicht so
knallig rüber wie zum Beispiel auf der
PSVR 2 mit OLED. Dennoch, der visuelle
Eindruck auf der Quest 3 ist super.
Das Sichtfeld der Quest 3 ist auch gut.
Etwas besser als bei der Quest 2
und fast so gut wie bei der PSVR 2
und der Valve Index, aber noch nicht perfekt.
Man hat also immer noch einen leichten
Klorollen- oder Fernglas-Effekt.
Es ist also nicht das komplette
Ich weiß halt immer noch nicht genau, wofür ich
jetzt verwenden würde.
Sichtfeld ausgefüllt.
Deswegen hätte ich einen richtig nicen Anwendungszweck
für mich. Ich hätte so ein Teil schon.
Aber ich habe seit ganz den Jahren
auch seit dem Hype, wo es den da drum gab,
nichts gefunden für mich, wo ich gesagt hätte,
oh ja, dafür lohnt sich das richtig.
Consumer Headset. Was ebenfalls beim optischen
System verbessert wurde, ihr könnt den
Augenabstand jetzt stufenlos einstellen.
Bei der Quest 2 gab es nur drei Stufen,
außerdem ist der Abstandsbereich größer.
Für Simracing. Okay Chat,
das kann ich mir vorstellen. Wenn man auf sowas steht,
Simracing, bestimmt auch
DCS oder sowas.
Flugsimulator-Kram.
Das ist bestimmt auch mega. Aber
nachdem ich beides nicht spiele.
50 Millimetern bis 75 Millimeter.
Das heißt, das Headset kann auch von Leuten getragen werden,
die einen ungewöhnlichen Augenabstand haben.
Ich persönlich bin da super durchschnittlich
unterwegs. Ich habe genau den weltweiten
Männerdurchschnittswert von 65
Millimetern. Allerdings bin ich da kurz
sichtig, weshalb ich eine Brille tragen muss.
Und das geht mit der Quest 3 genauso gut
oder schlecht, wie bei den Vorgängern.
Also es geht, aber ich finde es unangenehm.
Weil man, weil da immer irgendwas
rumwackelt und weil man auch immer Angst hat,
dass man die Gläser zerkratzt. Ich würde
deshalb so Dioptrien-Einklick-
Linsen empfehlen. Die werden ab demnächst
von Meta selbst vertrieben. Da kommen
die dann von der amerikanischen Firma Senni.
Oder ihr könnt die auch beim deutschen Hersteller
VR Optica bestellen.
VR Optician.
Verbesserung Nummer 3. Mehr
Rechenleistung. Die Quest 3 ist
wie alle Quests ja ein Standalone-
Headset. Habe ich ja schon gesagt. Es läuft also
autark, ohne angeschlossenen Rechner.
Denn es ist ja wie gesagt ein Rechner eingebaut.
Also ein Android-Mobilsystem und statt dem
System on a Chip Qualcomm
XR2 Gen 1 steckt da nun
ein XR2 Gen 2
drin. Hat auch ein bisschen mehr RAM. 8 GB
statt 6. Und da man auf Quest-Headsets
beliebige Android-Apps sideloaden kann,
haben wir mal Testweise, dass Benchmark...
Ja, das ist natürlich wirklich ein Vorteil.
...aktuell die
Gerade wenn man basteln will, ist so ein
Android-System unten drunter immer nice.
...Inch 6 installiert. Da kommen bei der
Quest 3 1706
Multicore-Punkte raus und bei der Quest 2
1470. Das ist ziemlich
wenig, was aber vermutlich daran liegt, dass
das Geekbench-Fenster ja in einer detaillierten
VR-Umgebung angezeigt wird. Das heißt,
das System nutzt den Großteil der Rechenleistung
fürs Umgebungsrendering und
nicht für Geekbench. VR-Apps
können dagegen ja die gesamte Leistung
abrufen. Schaut man sich allerdings Quest 2
Spiele an, die an Quest 3 angepasst
wurden, wird die zusätzliche Grafik-Power
sehr deutlich. Hier zum Beispiel RedMeta 2,
links Quest 2, rechts Quest 3.
Ja, auf jeden Fall gibt's einen Unterschied.
Super deutlich zu erkennen. Und auch in den
Menüs ist die Schruptizität
klar höher. Meta hat um es angekündigt,
dass mindestens 50 vorhandene Spiele an
die Quest 3 angepasst werden und es
50 neue Titel mit Quest 3
Support geben wird. Kritikpunkte.
Es gibt aber auch ein paar nicht so schöne Dinge.
Zum Beispiel die Akkulaufzeit. Mehr Leistung
bedeutet auch mehr Leistungsaufnahme, weshalb
die Quest 3 in unseren Tests auch
oft nach weniger als 2 Stunden
schon schlapp machte. Die Quest 2
Ich find, 2 Stunden am Stück geht eigentlich
voll klar für so ein Teil.
Länger willst du es wahrscheinlich
eh nicht am Stück aufhaben. Hat ne Idee
länger durchgehalten. Außerdem, und
das liegt wohl am kleinen Gehäuse, die
Quest 3 wird wärmer. Richtig schlimm
fand ich das nicht, aber ja, merkte
man schon. Und in beiden Headsets steckt
ein kleiner Lüfter. Den nimmt man in
VR nicht so richtig wahr,
ist aber bei der Quest 3 definitiv
etwas ausgeprägter zu hören.
Richtig unbefriedigend finde ich das
Softwareangebot zum Start. Die großen
angekündigten Titel wie Assassin's Creed
Nexus VR, Asgard's Wrath 2,
Ghostbusters und Stranger Things sind
alle noch nicht erhältlich. Schön wenigstens,
das umfangreiche Rollenspiel Asgard's
Wrath 2 bekommen alle gratis,
die eine Quest 3 kaufen.
Achso, die mehr als 1000 Quest 1
und 2 Apps laufen natürlich auf der
Quest 3 und wer die gekauft hat, muss
die nicht nochmal kaufen. Und klar, um Apps
zu kaufen und eine Quest zu nutzen,
braucht man einen Meta-Account.
Man braucht allerdings inzwischen keinen
Facebook-Account mehr, aber ohne...
Moment, da gibt's unterschiedliche Accounts?
Es gibt einen Meta-Account
und einen Facebook-Account. Und ein Facebook-
Account ist nicht automatisch ein Meta-Account?
Und, hä? Okay.
Ohne Meta-Account geht nix. Und ihr müsst
euch darüber im Klaren sein, dass wenn ihr
Mixed Reality nutzt, eure Umgebungsdaten,
also die groben Punktwolken
eures Raums, in die Cloud geschickt werden.
Und dass darauf auch die Apps zugreifen
können, die Mixed Reality unterstützen.
Das wird benötigt, wenn ihr zusammen mit anderen Leuten
in einem virtuellen Raum arbeiten oder
spielen wollt, dann braucht die App die
Rauminfo. Ihr könnt das deaktivieren,
dass das Zeugs in der Cloud landet, dann
funktionieren aber alle diese Multi-User
Sachen nicht mehr. Achso, und Meta hat wieder
keine ordentlichen Kopfhörer eingebaut.
Die Tonausgabe kommt nach wie vor
aus diesem kleinen Schlitz hier und klingt zwar
etwas besser als bei der Quest 2, aber
schön ist das trotzdem nicht. Zumindest
gibt's eine Klinkenbuchse, da könnt ihr dann Kabel-Kopfhörer
anschließen. Bluetooth geht zwar in der...
Klinkenbuchse!
Ja, ich bin ja begeistert,
dass es sowas 2023
noch gibt. Das wurde ja vor ein paar Jahren von
allen Herstellern abgeschafft.
Klinkenbuchse ist outdated, overrated,
keiner hat eine Klinkenbuchse dran.
Klinkenstecker!
Dabei ging das für gefühlt
50 Jahre oder so ganz gut.
Und es ist ja nicht so,
dass das irgendwie schlecht wäre, aber es hat den Herstellern
wahrscheinlich nicht so gepasst, dass man da einfach alles
dran anschließen kann, was man will.
Aber in der Praxis hat das eine viel zu
lange Verzögerung. Was ich auch noch wirklich schlecht
finde, die Quest 3 wird serienmäßig mit
einem ergonomisch völlig unbrauchbaren
Kopfband ausgeliefert. Das schneidet
nicht nur so ein hier an der Seite und
an den Ohren, sondern tut auch ganz schnell an der
Stirn weh. Wenn man das Teil einigermaßen
regelmäßig verwenden will, braucht man einen starren
Kopfriemen, der das Gewicht besser verteilt.
Meta verkauft das als Elite-Strap
für happige 80 Euro, aber
es gibt auch Drittanbieter, die sowas verkaufen.
Jedenfalls verstehe ich nicht, warum Meta... Kann man nicht
davon... Kann man nicht erwarten, dass bei... Das ist jetzt nicht
ultra-teuer, aber trotzdem teuer, dass da ein
gescheites Gummiband
oder was auch immer dabei ist, dass man das benutzen
kann. Das headset nicht direkt mit einem
brauchbaren Kopfriemen anbietet.
Fazit. Bevor mein Fazit kommt, hier mal
kurz der Eindruck von meinem Kollegen Jan-Philipp
Wöbbelking, der die Quest 3 fürs
CT-Präzision und heise online getestet
hat. Also nachdem ich jetzt die Quest 3 ein paar
Tage ausprobiert habe, ist es wirklich schwer, wieder
zur Quest 2 zurückzukehren, weil
das Bild ist halt nochmal eine ganze Ecke klarer
und schicker und
durch diese Pancake-Linsen ist sie halt auch schön
kompakt. Und natürlich, was auch
faszinierend ist, ist einfach mal diese AR-Modi
und AR-Spiele auszuprobieren oder
Mixed Reality, auch wenn das oft halt noch wie ein Gimmick
wirkt. Das ist halt das Ding, das ist
cool und es hat so richtige, wahrscheinlich
richtiger Wow-Effekt. Das Problem
ist, das verliert ganz schnell
die Begeisterung da dran. Das probierst du mal
eine Woche lang immer mal wieder aus und dann startest
das nie wieder. Und sollte mit dein Zukunft
auch noch mehr bringen in der Richtung. Hast du auch irgendwie...
Hast du auch einen Kritikpunkt an der Quest 3?
Ist dir auch was Negatives aufgefallen?
Ja, also der Akku, der ist wahnsinnig schnell leer.
So schon in unter zwei Stunden.
Ja, muss da wieder an die Ladestation.
Und ja...
Ja, sehe ich alles ähnlich. Die Quest 3 ist
quasi in allen Belangen der Quest 2
überlegen. Lediglich die Akkulaufzeit ist
eine Idee kürzer, aber ich hatte ja schon am Anfang gesagt, dass
man eigentlich eh nach spätestens einer Stunde
eine Pause machen will. Zumindest für mich
passt das also. Wenn ihr mit dem Gedanken spielt,
euch erstmals ein VR
bzw. Mixed Reality Headset zu kaufen,
könnt ihr auf jeden Fall zuschlagen. Ihr kriegt
zurzeit kein besseres Standalone
Headset als die Quest 3. Wenn ihr
eine Quest 2 habt, würde sich ein
Umstieg langfristig lohnen.
Das müsst ihr aber nicht überstürzen, weil
es zurzeit noch nicht wirklich viel an die
Quest 3 angepasste Software gibt. Ja, und wenn
ihr Apple-Fans seid und sehr, sehr
viel mehr Geld ausgeben wollt, dann
solltet ihr vielleicht auf die Vision Pro warten.
Die kann zwar in der grundsätzlichen
Funktionalität nicht viel mehr als die
Quest 3, aber ihr bekommt höhere Auflösung,
Augen- und Gesichtstracking...
Ich werd mir nach wie vor keine kaufen.
Apple Experience. Aber was ihr nicht
kriegt... Weder Apple noch Quest.
...die haben halt in den letzten Jahren
eine Bibliothek mit über 1.000
Spielen und Apps aufgebaut. Das ist
meines Erachtens das größte
Alleinstellungsmerkmal. Wenn ihr übrigens
mehr und detailliertere Videos zur Quest 3
und über VR... Moment, Moment, was
ist das für eine Spielekategorie?
Honoring
Woman in VR...
Ach nein!
Sie ehren...
Das ist nicht die Spielekategorie.
Ich hab schon gedacht, was soll das sein?
Sie
highlighten Spiele...
VR-Spiele von weiblichen Entwicklern.
Jetzt hab ich das gecheckt.
Was zum Teufel ist das für eine komische
Game-Kategorie?
Wenn ihr übrigens mehr und detailliertere
Videos zur Quest 3 und über VR
allgemein sehen wollt, es gibt hier
auf YouTube einige sehr kompetente
deutschsprachige Leute, die sich ausschließlich
VR und MR widmen. Zum Beispiel
VoodooVR, MRTV,
ZockstubeVR und MoFranVR.
Kann ich euch ans Herz legen, guckt da mal
rein. Ich hab die Channel hier in der Beschreibung
verlinkt. Achso, ja, und gerne eure
Meinung zu VR, MR und dem
ganzen Rest in die Kommentare schreiben,
das hilft uns immer sehr herauszufinden, was euch so interessiert.
Die Kommentare zu eliminieren.
Also ich werd mir auch nach wie vor nichts kaufen.
Ich hab einfach
keinen Anwendungszweck dafür.
So cool ich
Bastelsachen und neue Technik finde, so ganz
ohne irgendwas, was ich damit
machen will, macht's ja dann auch keinen Sinn,
sich das zu kaufen. Kann ich das
anklicken, ohne dass da irgendwas Schlimmes passiert?
Okay.
Ja.
Beim Zug weiß man nie.
Hast du dir scheinbar einen Raspberry Pi
bestellt? Ab wann ist das denn
vorbestellbar oder ist das, oder bestellbar ist das
jetzt schon?
BerryBase, BerryBase, gucken wir mal.
Ja, wenn man sowas wie SimRacing
macht oder DCS,
Flugsimulator spielt, dann verstehe ich
das. Würde ich das machen, hätte ich wahrscheinlich
auch schon eins, aber mach ich ja
nicht. So, Raspberry
Pi 6.
Wo gibt's denn den hier? Pi 6.
Haben die noch, kam die noch gar keinen drinnen stehen?
Oh, bei Geiz halt.
Achso, wir sind beim Fünfer, nicht beim
Sechser. Ups.
Wie, wie komm ich, wie komm ich auf Raspberry
Pi? Achso, weil wir das
Video gesehen haben, Pi Hole 6
vorhin, wo ich mir gedacht hab, hä?
Ja, ja, wir sind,
wir sind bei 5. Ja, Raspberry
Raspberry Pi
leider nicht verfügbar. Ja,
da hab ich ehrlich gesagt auch mit gerechnet.
Ab 23.
Oktober.
Ja, dann warten wir mal ab, ne?
Raspberry
Pi 5.
125.
Das ist 8G-Modell, trotzdem.
Nö, ich wart mal ab, ich wart mal ab.
Ich mein, ich brauch keinen neuen Raspberry Pi.
Ich hab noch genug übrig
hier und ich hab auch keine
Anwendungszwecke, gerade für zusätzliche weitere
Raspberry Pis, also insofern.
Oh, mal abwarten.
Bevor du den holst,
schau das hier.
Was ist das?
Hey, das sind, das sind die mit den
Windows, mit diesem, mit diesem
komischen Windows Tuning Pack.
Was ich sehr fragwürdig fand.
Ne, ich glaube nicht,
dass das eine sinnvolle
Konkurrenz für einen Raspberry Pi ist.
Und warum nicht? Weil der Raspberry
Pi nicht nur Hardware ist.
Der Raspberry Pi ist eine komplette
Kombination aus
mehreren Dingern als Plattform.
Nämlich sehr viele Third-Party
Sachen, die direkt beispielsweise
den GPIO
Pin-Header unterstützen als Add-on.
Massig
Tutorials, super
offizieller Linux Support und nicht
irgend so was halbherziges.
Also du wirst sicherlich
Hardware finden, die für den
gleichen Preis oder ein bisschen mehr
oder ein bisschen weniger, was auch immer,
deutlich performanter ist
oder vielleicht auch die deutlich, ja,
vielleicht modernere Plattform ist,
was auch immer. Aber die Kombination
aus Ökosystem,
also aus
der Hardware, dem Preis
und dem Ökosystem drumherum, ist
der Raspberry Pi unschlagbar und wird wahrscheinlich
auch der Fünfer in nächster
Zeit da nichts rankommen.
Ich meine, wir können ja mal reinkommen.
Was will er uns?
Ja, guck mal!
Allein schon der Formfaktor
Allein schon der Formfaktor kommt nicht hin.
Die Größe meine ich nicht, aber
da kannst du
wahrscheinlich nicht mal irgendwelche GPIO
Raspberry Pi Add-Ons dranpappen,
gescheit.
Also ich, wie gesagt,
da gehört mehr dazu, als
eine Hardware rauszubringen, die ähnlich viel kostet
und performanter ist.
Aber ihr könnt trotzdem mal gucken.
Das hier ist ein
Mini-PC, der
so groß ist, wie ein Raspberry Pi,
doppelt so schnell ist, wie
ein Raspberry Pi, weniger
kostet, wie ein Raspberry Pi.
Ja, aber alles drum herum nicht hat, was ein Raspberry Pi hat.
Raspberry Pi und
upgradbar ist
mit PC Express 2.0
und hier das Beste, er zieht maximal
10 Watt im Betrieb, eher eigentlich so
6 bis 8. Rein ins Video!
Mega geil!
Liebe es!
Also, ich, wie gesagt,
ich bin da äußerst skeptisch.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es eine sinnvolle Raspberry Pi
Alternative ist, aber mal gucken.
Oh, ist ja gut jetzt!
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp!
Wird ja viel zu laut.
Das Ding sieht aus...
Wisst ihr, wie es aussieht?
Es sieht aus, wie eine SSD-Verpackung,
die oft besonders fancy gemacht ist.
Also, eines der Riesensachen,
die Raspberry Pi ja auch auszeichnen,
ist, dass du beispielsweise
sowas hier einfach anschließen kannst.
Du hast beispielsweise so ein
Modul, das passt 1 zu 1
auf den GPIO-Header
vom Raspberry Pi drauf.
Lässt dich draufstecken und gut ist.
Und schon hast du auf einen Schlag
ein Relay, was du schalten kannst,
Analog-Digital-Converter,
digitale
Inputs, Outputs
und noch ein paar zusätzliche Sachen,
die durchgeschleift werden vom Raspberry Pi.
Und das kannst du halt mit vielen anderen Sachen
nicht so einfach machen. Dazu kriegst du eine fertige
Python-Library, die auf dem Raspberry Pi gut läuft
und gut integriert ist.
Wenn du sowas brauchst,
tun es halt andere Plattformen nicht.
Zumal ich gelesen habe, dass
der Raspberry Pi 5 sogar
einen Analog-Digital-Converter
mittlerweile auf
den GPIOs mit drauf hat.
Der glaube ich sogar offiziell jetzt
3,3 Volt bis zu
oder bis zu 5 Volt tolerant
ist. War er ja
meistens vorher auch schon, aber offiziell
nicht. Ne, Moment. Oder umgedreht?
Ne, ne, ne.
Das war der Raspberry Pi. Der Raspberry Pi
war ja oftmals bei den GPIO-Pins
nicht 5 Volt tolerant.
Oder war das
umgedreht, die Geräte sind kaputt gegangen,
weil er 5 Volt standardmäßig hatte?
Ne, ne.
Ich glaube, der brauchte 3,3
Volt auf den GPIO-Pins.
Also, allein schon aus dem
Grund würde ich sagen,
hast du halt...
Das kannst du nur mit dem Raspberry Pi gescheit machen.
Das hier
ist das Zima Blade.
Was ist das Zima Blade?
Der Nachfolger des Zima Boards
kommt in dieser
Verpackung. Und das hier war das
Zima Board. Hier haben wir
den Vergleich. Die erste
Version, die zweite Version.
Wo sind die Unterschiede, was können sie?
Das Ding habe ich doch schon mal irgendwo
gesehen. Haben wir da nicht schon mal
ein Video drüber geguckt und ich habe gesagt, das ist
keine sinnvolle Alternative zu einem Raspberry Pi?
Wer noch nicht weiß, was ein Zima Board ist,
das hier ist ein 8 Watt
PC mit PC-Express 2.0
mit USB, Doppel Ethernet, Display
Out, Strom und das war's.
Hinten zwei SATA-Anschläge.
RAM einbauen.
Die können den RAM...
Das Ding hat...
Das Ding hat doch nicht mal einen GPIO-Header, oder?
Richtig?
Das ist überhaupt keine Alternative
zum Raspberry Pi. Das ist eine Alternative
je nach Anwendungszweck
vielleicht. Aber dann ist
der Anwendungszweck wahrscheinlich auch nicht
sinnvoll geeignet für einen Raspberry Pi.
Also, das hat ja...
Hat das ein GPIO...
Hat das ein GPIO-Output? Ich habe jetzt
nichts erkannt.
Zumindest wahrscheinlich nicht
der PC-Express.
Ich meine, du kriegst ja so ein Add-on-Board
gar nicht gescheit
in das Gehäuse rein.
Naja. Also wie gesagt,
ich bleibe dabei, das ist keine richtig
gute Raspberry Pi-Alternative,
weil der Raspberry Pi ein Gesamtsystem
ist, außer Party-Sachen und
vor allem super Linux-Support
und ganz viele Tutorials und Anleitungen
und Sachen drumherum, was man so mit
anderen Boards nicht kriegt.
Ich hatte ja mal den Vergleich, ich habe mir ja mal
so einen Odroid
HC2 gekauft.
Das ist auch so ein Single-Board-Computer,
der da drauf ist. Ist auch ziemlich klein,
wie ihr seht. Guckt hier, das ist das einzige, was ist.
Und das war leistungsmäßig damals
auch schon, dieses kleine Furzding,
rein CPU-technisch, besser
als
der Raspberry Pi.
Aber ich habe es da gemerkt, der
Linux-Support, auch wenn, also
nicht so, dass da Windows drauf laufen würde oder so.
Das gibt es nur mit Linux.
Aber der Linux-Support war nicht mal
not even close,
wie gut das unter dem Raspberry Pi funktioniert hat.
Du hattest da zig Probleme. Wir haben ja im Stream
auch damit rumgebaut. Du hattest zig Probleme
und irgendwann mussten wir sogar
einen eigenen Kernel dafür
kompilieren, dass es überhaupt USB-Geräte
erkannt hat. Und das sind halt so
Dinger mit...
Die Sachen hast du im Raspberry Pi einfach nicht.
Der geht in der Regel.
Ich denke nicht, dass das eine sinnvolle Alternative
ist. Ob ich nicht.
Chat, ratet mal, was es bei mir heute zu essen
gibt. Ich gebaide euch auch nicht.
Nudel mit Lachs, korrekt.
Ihr habt Recht.
Nudel mit Lachs gibt es heute.
Und dabei,
also oben drüber,
wahrscheinlich bisschen China-Chinesen
Süß-Sauer-Soße.
Weil so
Nudel mit Lachs ohne was dabei
ist ja auch ein bisschen trocken.
Moin Patrick, was für
Nudel?
Äh, Moment.
Ich glaub so...
Die da, die da. Fusilli.
Fusilli.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht.
Geschweige denn, ob es überhaupt italienisch ist.
Oder irgendeine deutsche Erfindung, die sich italienisch anhören soll.
Keine Ahnung.
Die hier.
Ich hau ein bisschen China-Süß-Sauer-Soße drauf.
Reicht.
Ja, Spiral-Nudel, ne?
Das klingt...
Klingt schon sehr deutsch,
der Name.
Half-Life 2 RTX Remix.
So.
Ich will mal nur Graphics angucken.
Und das jetzt mit RTX?
Also in meiner Erinnerung sah
Half-Life 2 genau so aus.
Okay, die Schattenwürfe vielleicht nicht,
aber in meiner Erinnerung
sah das zumindest so aus.
Ich muss eh sagen, Half-Life 2 ist
von wann? 2004 oder so?
Äh.
Was ist denn jetzt gerade?
Ich hab irgendwie den...
Na geil.
Den Verlauf aufgemacht.
Half-Life 2
Release Date.
Oder... 2004, ja.
Also ich finde, Half-Life 2
ist wirklich gut gealtert.
Half-Life 2
geht grafisch heute auch noch
ganz gut klar.
Ja, haben wir sogar schon ein paar von geguckt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Kenn ich. Haben wir ein paar schon geguckt.
Ich glaub sogar die drei
haben wir schon geguckt, ja.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas spannendes?
Was nicht so lang geht, weil ich krieg langsam
wirklich Hunger.
Bewachtes Chlorinko.
What the fuck? Was ist das?
Der teuerste Kopfhörer
der Welt im Test
versus AirPods Max.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das...
Sind das nicht diese...
Die mega Apple-Fans
hier auf dem... Wobei, nee, dann verwechsel ich
den Channel. Da kommt doch bestimmt
raus... Okay, Fazit wird sein,
die 70.000 Euro Kopfhörer
sind besser, aber nicht viel
und deswegen alle AirPods kaufen oder sowas.
Was wird's
zu essen geben? Ja, was wohl?
Was könnte es wohl nur zu essen geben?
Also das ist er nicht. Der
kostet das zehntausendfache weniger
7 Euro. Wieso wir diesen absurden Vergleich
ziehen und außerdem die AirPods Max
und diesen 5.000 Euro Kopfhörer mit ins
Ach nur! Das ist
aber schwach. Nur den 5.000 Euro
Kopfhörer.
...schicken, das erfahrt ihr gleich.
Der HR1 der deutschen Firma
Sennheiser ist unter Audiophilen der Referenz
Kopfhörer schlechthin. Auf YouTube fangen
Tester regelmäßig an zu weinen,
weil sie vom Sounderlebnis so ergriffen...
Okay, das ist...
Das ist eben so Marketing-Shit.
Das ist... Guck mal, die Leute haben sogar
bei Windows 11 geweint. Aus Freude
angeblich.
Also, wenn die geweint
haben, dann wahrscheinlich wegen anderen Sachen.
Aber laut Marketing natürlich, weil sie so
emotional mitgerissen waren.
Wir durften den
HR1 als einer der wenigen eingeladenen
Journalisten aus der ganzen Welt in
der Sennheiser Manufaktur in Irland
testen und zeigen euch, ob auch mir die Tränen
in die Augen geschossen sind. Also, worauf
warten wir noch? Abwarten! Das Ding müsste wahrscheinlich
im Leben keine 70.000 Euro kosten.
Das kostet 70.000
Euro, um es noch... Das ist
bestimmt irgendein Pfeifert-Marketing-Trick,
um es eben besonders
noch mehr Premium wirken
zu lassen.
So, man hat halt einfach das Beste gebaut,
was man bauen konnte. Hätte es
dann entweder für
8.000, 9.000 oder 70.000,
dann hat man einfach gesagt 70.000 Euro.
Weil es sich noch mehr Premium anfühlt
dann.
Also, ich gebe ja auch mal ganz gerne
für gute Hardware ordentlich Geld aus.
Ja? Aber 70.000 Euro
für einen Kopfhörer? Ne.
Ich möchte,
dass ihr in diesem Video wirklich ein
Gefühl dafür bekommt, wie sich Kopfhörer
für 70.000 Euro klanglich
von bezahlbaren Modellen unterscheiden.
Ja, am besten mache ich das hier gerade
mit meinen 30 Euro... Ah, ne, Moment.
Immerhin habe ich mein
Biodynamics-Headset drauf. Das geht dann schon ein bisschen.
...was man da eigentlich mehr für sein Geld bekommt.
Und dazu müssen wir einfach mal ganz unten
anfangen. Auf der Suche nach dem günstigsten Schrott,
den man so auf dem Markt finden kann, sind wir
auf die Hama Slide gestoßen. Und ich
weiß, es klingt absurd, aber dieser 7 Euro
Kopfhörer hier, der soll gleich eine wichtige
Sache verdeutlichen. Schauen wir uns das Ding mal an.
Fällt auf, weniger Verarbeitung
geht eigentlich nicht. Dann kommt man eigentlich nur
zu dem Schluss, dass man jeglichen Anspruch
an Musikgenuss aufgegeben hat, wenn man
diesen Dingern überhaupt irgendwas abge...
Vor allem sind es auch noch so...
...on-ear
Dinger, die dann drücken
nach einer Zeit. Aber gut, 7 Euro...
Ach, kommt Hammer nicht aus Bayern?
...winnen kann. Wenn ihr aber bereit seid,
das Zehnfache auf den Tisch zu legen, also
70 Euro, dann bekommt ihr schon deutlich
mehr geboten. Das sind dann auch Leute,
die sowas, die so 70.000 Euro,
für ein Kopfhörer ausgeben, die haben dann auch vergoldete
Ölbach-Kabel
oder sowas. So irgendwelche vergoldeten
Klinkestecker und so komisches
Placebo-Zeug.
L-Headphones bieten Bluetooth,
Active Noise Cancelling, Multi-Point
Connection, Hands-Free Calls und
Voice Control. Ihr bekommt also viel
mehr Funktion und Qualität als beim
7 Euro Kopfhörer. Und man muss
kein Audiophiler sein, um zu verstehen,
dass diese Dinger vom Klang her immer noch
etwas dröge klingen und auch
stimmgewaltige Tracks bleiben einfach
deutlich hinter den Erwartungen.
Wenn wir versuchen, die JBL preislich nochmal um,
naja, nicht ganz das Zehnfache zu steigern,
dann trifft man auf die... Man könnte auch einfach
mal eine 0815,
keine Ahnung, irgendwas von
AKG 701,
sonst was, mit ganz normalem Kabel dran nehmen,
mal einen ordentlichen
Kopfhörerverstärker
anschließen und ich wette,
die meisten Leute, auch super krass
Hyper-Audiophile,
hätten Probleme
jetzt zu sagen, bei einem
Test, welcher denn jetzt der
bessere, teurere Kopfhörer ist.
Kopfhörer haben alle
ein bisschen unterschiedliches Klangbild,
ja, das lass ich mir gefallen, aber
es ist
schwer, da jetzt zu sagen,
okay, das ist der für 7000,
das ist der für 400 Euro, das ist der für
70.000, ich glaube,
das ist gar nicht so einfach, wenn man das wirklich mal
blind testen würde. Wenn natürlich das
gescheit angeschlossen ist,
fängt der schon mit irgendwelchen
Noise-Canceling-Wireless-Dingern,
die nur alles Bluetooth,
was weiß ich, 3. irgendwas
unterstützen, an.
Ja, also, die wahrscheinlich
nicht, die ist wahrscheinlich besser,
aber man könnte sich einfach mal
das nehmen, vergleichen das mit
irgendeinem gescheiten
Ding mit Kabel dran, anschließen,
ich glaube, die meisten Leute könnten es nicht
auseinanderhalten. Das kommt ja schon
daher, dass viele Leute,
ich will mich da jetzt nicht aufspielen,
ich bin besser oder so,
aber viele Leute empfinden Badewannenklang
als besser.
Ja?
So nach dem Motto, Badewannenklang ist halt
sowas mit Boosts in
gewissen, so Bass, bisschen
Bassboost, bisschen Höhenboost,
vor allem Badewannen.
Ja? So, und
die denken, wow, das hat richtig satter
Sound, wow, das klingt richtig gut,
dass es die Hälfte von
anderen Sachen verschluckt, ist dann egal, aber
klingt halt gut, weil, ne, bam.
Ist wahrscheinlich auch der einzige Grund,
warum Beats Kopfhörer früher beliebt
waren. Und wenn man dann einen Kopfhörer
hat, der ein bisschen neutraler
klingt, da sagen
viele, oh, das klingt so flach,
und oh, das ist so, so, so,
so hat er das wenig mitreißen
und sowas, wo ich mir denke, ja gut, es kommt
halt immer drauf an, was man haben will, so pauschal
kann man das nicht sagen, jeder hat
ein bisschen andere so Hörgewohnheiten, deswegen
ich glaube, die wenigsten Leute könnten es unterscheiden,
wenn du denen mal gescheite Kopfhörer aufsetzt,
ob, die
wenigsten könnten den 70.000 Euro Kopfhörer
da raushören. Außerdem würde ich mir
genau, das kommt ja auch noch dazu,
Noise Cancelling Kopfhörer würde ich jetzt auch gar nicht so
sehr rein nach high-endigster
Soundqualität aussuchen, sondern wie gut
das Noise Cancelling ist.
Und wie easy die Bedienung ist vor allem, weil
du willst ja auch mal mit Knopfdruck zum Beispiel
Noise Cancelling einen ausmachen,
ja, es ist alles, es ist viel
Geschmackssache dabei.
Sind genauso
wie die Leute, die immer behaupten,
sie hören Audio prinzipiell nur
unkomprimiert, weil ihnen
die Soundqualität von MP3s zu schlecht
ist. Ich weiß,
wir haben sogar im Chat Leute,
die das immer behaupten, aber es gibt
Tests, wo die
Leute blind
Audiofiles haben vorgespielt bekommen,
komprimiert, unkomprimiert,
mittelmäßig gutes MP3,
gutes MP3,
und die Allermeisten konnten noch nicht mal
mittelmäßiges
MP3 zu unkomprimiert
unterscheiden.
Also da ist viel
Bildung dabei in diesem Audio-Sektor.
Ja, und
es gibt ja auch noch mehr Sachen, was Kopfhörer
und Headsets unterscheidet.
Gibt ja welche, da hast du eher den
Eindruck, dass
der Fachmann bei Kopfhörern nennt sich das dann
breite Bühne. Fragt mich nicht,
wer sich das überlegt hat. Hat ja
jeder, jeder Bereich
hat ja so eigene Fachbegriffe,
bei Kopfhörern nennt sich das dann breite Bühne.
Also sprich,
ähm, ja, wie, wie,
wie, wie, schwer zu sagen,
wie gut
kannst du verschiedene
Sachen noch raushören, wie breit
hört sich das alles an.
Ja, bei manchen hört sich das eher,
eher kompakt an, bei anderen eben besonders breit.
Das gibt es nicht so
pauschal, das Ding. Und die meisten Leute
behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal, könnten es nicht unterscheiden.
So.
... durchaus beliebten AirPods Max. Im bezahlbaren
Consumer-Bereich ein geschlossener Kopfhörer,
der für viele qualitativ schon sehr
weit oben mitspielt. Und absolut, ich weiß,
die AirPods Max sind nicht günstig, aber sie bieten
ein gutes Gesamtpaket aus Design, Tragekomfort
und natürlich einer sehr guten
Audioqualität. Das Aluminium,
Textilgewebe und die gummierten Bügel wirken
darüber hinaus einfach deutlich hochwertiger
als der Kunststoff bei den JBL. Nun
will ich euch aber erklären, warum wir diese seltsamen
und auf jeden Fall auch unfairen Vergleiche
ziehen, denn es verdeutlicht ganz gut, dass
wir im Preisbereich unter 500 Euro
ziemlich große Sprünge machen. Sowohl
was die Qualität angeht, als auch
das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis. Wir hätten hier auch
die Sony XM5 gezeigt. Das, das
stimmt schon. Ne, es ist ein riesen
Unterschied zwischen einem
super billigen
5 Euro
Amazon Basics Kopfhörer
oder irgendwas für 50, 60 Euro
von einem halbwegs kompetenten Hersteller.
Also was, was jetzt ganze
Zeit lang so ein Geheimtipp war an
günstigen Kopfhörern, waren diese Superlux
Dinger. Die, die,
das ist glaube ich der Hersteller, der normalerweise,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, für Sennheiser oder für
Beyerdynamics die Kopfhörer herstellt,
hergestellt hat,
bin mir nicht sicher, ob das noch so ist.
Das war vor ein paar Jahren so.
Und die waren, waren
eine zeitlange richtige Preis-Leistungs-Empfehlung
immer.
Die waren günstig und
für den Preis wirklich nice.
... für um die 300 Euro
und hätten ebenfalls einen vielfach besseren
Klang als bei den 70 Euro
JBL Kopfhörern. Und das ist wichtig
zu verstehen, denn ihr werdet gleich merken, dass
die eigenen Erwartungen an viel
teurere Kopfhörer eigentlich gar nicht erfüllt
werden können. Denn das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis
wächst eben nicht proportional mit.
Ja, da hat er recht.
... dieser Kopfhörer hier.
Das hier ist der Focal Utopia
für 5000 Euro.
Die haben doch auch Boxen, oder?
Die haben doch so geschwungene,
so geschwungene
Boxen haben die doch.
Ja, die Dinger.
Die auch irgendwie...
...
Also man kann's auch echt übertreiben,
Mann.
Tja.
Einfach, einfach ein bisschen Kohle
ausgeben. Wer hat nicht mal eine Viertelmillion
übrig, um sich ein bisschen Audio-Equipment zu kaufen?
Bestellen und dann wieder
zurückschicken.
Und auch unter
audiophilen Fans ist das hier kein Schnäppchen
mehr. Aber wenn er so viel teurer
ist, dann muss er doch auch wirklich viel
mehr auf Kasten haben, oder?
Naja, also lass es mich so erklären.
Dem Kunden, der sich für ein solches Modell interessiert,
der fährt natürlich damit keine U-Bahn, sondern
genießt die Dinger zu Hause im doppelt so teurem
Ledersessel. Der Kopfhörer muss also
auch kein Active Noise Cancelling oder sowas mitbringen.
Im Gegenteil.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt braucht er das wirklich nicht. Wenn ich mir einen Kopfhörer kaufe,
hier für, um da mit Musik
zu hören oder an PC anzuschließen,
der ist sogar hinderlich, wenn der Noise Cancelling
hat. Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Produktkategorien.
Und außerdem braucht man so einen tollen Kopfhörer
dafür gar nicht.
Es gibt, gebe ich ihm
voll recht, also es gibt super Kopfhörer
im Bereich von 150
bis 300 Euro. Da fährt
er sich preis-leistungsmäßig richtig gut
dabei. Und es gibt auch richtig gute Preis-Leistungs-Sachen
für, sagen wir mal, unter 50 Euro.
... finden sich vor allem
in diesem Preissegment offene Bauweisen.
Im Gegensatz zu den AirPods Max kann man
das gut zeigen. Die Hörmuscheln der AirPods sind
komplett geschlossen. Das Aluminium ist dicht,
Schallwellen kommen also schlechter rein,
aber auch raus. Die Utopia sind geöffnet.
Die Muschel ist perforiert, der Schall
hat also... Ja, das ist daheim natürlich
sinnvoll, wenn du noch was mitbekommen
willst von deiner Umwelt. Ja, wenn du hören
willst, dass das Telefon klingelt oder dass
irgendjemand... dass DHL
da ist oder dass irgendwie einer
aus dem Erdgeschoss was ruft und so, ist das
nicht verkehrt. Natürlich hören die Leute
drumherum dann auch ein bisschen mehr.
Aber das ist
je nachdem, wo man sitzt, gar nicht mal so
wild. Also ich finde offene Kopfhörer
oder es gibt ja auch halboffene
tatsächlich ganz angenehm daheim.
Jetzt habe ich gerade das MMX 300 auf,
das ist ja komplett geschlossen, auch
also mit Ohr rein und da ist
hörst du teilweise
echt schwierig was, gerade wenn man
noch Musik laufen hat.
Freie Fahrt vom Ohr weg.
Zwar scheiden sich hier manchmal die Geister, welche
Bauweise jetzt die bessere ist. Fakt ist
aber, der Schall strömt nach außen ab
und wird nicht von der Hörmuschelwand wieder
ins Ohr reflektiert. Das führt auch dazu,
dass jeder im Raum mitbekommt, was ihr
auf einem offenen Kopfhörer gerade hört.
Aber so ist dieser doch etwas massiv
wirkende Kopfhörer etwas leichter
und buchstäblich offener im Klang
zugunsten der räumlichen Darstellung
eben. Und ja, diesen Unterschied kann
man auf jeden Fall wahrnehmen, wenn...
Ja.
Es gibt Leute, die erkennen
auch den Unterschied nicht, also ich
denke die meisten würden das tatsächlich
auch hören. Es gibt auch Leute, um
jetzt mal ein Beispiel aus der anderen Richtung zu bringen,
es gibt auch Leute, die erkennen den Unterschied
zwischen 15 und 60 FPS nicht.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht von 30
auf 60 gehen. Es gibt Leute,
die erkennen 15 zu 60
nicht.
Es ist mir unbegreiflich, wie das möglich
ist, dass man von Geruckel
zu superflüssig gehen kann
und Leute erkennen es nicht, aber das ist
möglich, das gibt es.
Ja, sorry, ich habe ja vergessen, das Auge sieht nur 12 FPS.
Ja, richtig, richtig.
... eine breite Bühne.
Im Fachjargon beschreibt man damit, wie auch beim
Hören mit Lautsprechern, den visuellen
Eindruck. Man sitzt als Zuhörer vor
der Bühne und kann die einzelnen Musiker
mit ihren Instrumenten orten. Ja, genau.
Das funktioniert beim Fokal sehr gut.
Außerdem treten Stimmen mehr in den Vordergrund
und betrieben mit einem externen Kopfhörerverstärker
entfalten die Fokal auch einfach
nochmal mehr Power und eine viel höhere
Lautstärke ohne klanglich dabei
auszubrechen. Aber klar, wer solche Kopfhörer
kauft, der spart am Ende auch nicht am
Zubehör und dann kann so ein Kopfhörerverstärker
hier auch schon mal 2600
Euro kosten.
Ich halte das auch für sehr viel
wie soll ich sagen so
sehr viel Gefühl
dabei.
Also, natürlich hört man einen Unterschied
zwischen einem ganz
billigen Verstärker, der am besten auch
wild anfängt zu rauschen beim
beim Einstöpseln irgendwo versus
den ganz guten.
Es gibt ja Leute, die gehen so weit und sagen
sie nehmen nur Verstärker mit Röhren drin
und sowas. Da gibt's
sehr viel Glaubenssachen und
aber wie gesagt
ab einem gewissen
Qualitätsniveau
95% der Leute
können auch nicht mal mehr Mittel zu gut unterscheiden.
Also diese Kopfhörer richten sich
natürlich an Menschen, die den Unterschied
hören können und auch wollen und das
gelingt am besten, wenn man sie direkt miteinander
vergleicht und deswegen haben wir die Focal
auch mitgenommen nach Irland
in die Manufaktur, wo von einem deutschen
Hersteller die teuersten Kopfhörer
der Welt gebaut werden.
Der Sennheiser HE1.
Hat fast schon
was von dem Halo Intro.
Ah, ok, ok, guck
der hat auch Röhren.
Als Verstärker.
Also im Verstärker.
Da gibt's ja welche, die schwören da total drauf.
Wenn du an gute Verarbeitungsqualität zu glauben bist,
vergesst alles über perfekten
Klang. Eins kann ich schon mal vorwegnehmen,
der Sound aus dem HE1
war das Beste, das jemals auf meine Ohren
getroffen ist. Aber trotzdem
kann ich gleich sagen. Klingt besser als echt.
Davor möchte ich euch aber meinen Eindruck schildern.
Und natürlich schaltet man die
HE1 nicht einfach an und hört drauf los.
Zuallererst muss man das prunkvolle Stück
aus seinem Dornröschenschlaf befreien.
Fast wie bei einem Ritual fahren zuerst
die Bedienelemente aus dem von einem
Steinmetz gefertigten massiven Block
Marmor heraus.
Da sieht man mal, da ist sehr viel,
da wird sehr viel Bullshit mit verkauft, Mann.
Daraufhin
machen sich acht Röhrenverstärker auf den Weg,
sich aus einem Sockel zu schieben, um sich
Es ist natürlich enorm wichtig,
dass mein Verstärker in einem Block
sitzt, der von einem Steinmetz
von Hand gesteinmetzt wurde.
Anschließend
glühen die einzelnen Röhren auf. Denn tatsächlich
dient dieser andauernde Moment dazu,
dass sich die Vorverstärker aufwärmen,
um ihre optimale Betriebstemperatur
aufzubauen.
Anschließend öffnet sich die magische
Schatulle, in der die HE1 aufgebettet
Das sie aufwärmen müssen, ist bei Röhren,
das ist tatsächlich normal.
Und auch hier wird die Zeit genutzt,
um den Kopfhörer aufzuladen, denn schließlich
handelt es sich beim HE1 um einen
elektrostatischen Kopfhörer.
Ihr merkt also schon, der Kunde zahlt hier
für ein ganzheitliches Ergebnis.
Das ist alles so weit weg vom Konsumereinheitsbrei,
den wir uns leisten können.
Aber dient es am Ende dazu,
einfach davon abzulenken, dass der HE1
am Ende genauso klingt, wie jeder andere
hochwertige Kopfhörer?
Die Antwort lautet, nein.
Denn zum einen dient dieser ganze Vorlauf
keinem Ablenkungsmanöver, sondern ist
Teil der technischen Aufwärmphase.
Naja, ein bisschen auch.
Oh, wir erleben
jetzt gleich was ganz Tolles
und ist ja da auch schon dabei.
Ja, Erlebnis soll das sein.
Darüber hinaus würde ich den HE1 einfach
als kompromisslos beschreiben.
Es wäre jetzt vermessen zu behaupten, dass ich schon mal
einen HE1-Kopfhörer habe.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das würde ich mir nicht kaufen.
Wie gesagt, ich gebe gerne Geld aus
für ordentliche Hardware.
Aber ich gucke immer noch drauf, dass man irgendwie
was für kriegt.
Ich kaufe mir nie sinnlos einfach nur was.
... Kopfhörer auf dem Kopf hatte, der einfach besser klingt.
Ich würde es so beschreiben.
Der HE1 klingt einfach warm, absolut stimmig
und bietet Audiophilen die Möglichkeit,
jedes Instrument auf der Bühne herauszuhören
und räumlich einzuordnen.
Und einfach eine Wohltat für die Ohren.
Aber es gibt ein Aber.
Und das setzt genau da an, wo wir
vorhin aufgehört haben.
Das Ding ist halt,
selbst wenn ein Kopfhörer
sich nicht
exakt perfekt anhört,
wie man es jetzt gerne hätte,
dann ist die beste Variante nicht,
man sucht einen Kopfhörer,
der sich dann exakt immer so anhört,
was je nach Musik oder Anwendungszweck
unterschiedlich ist, sondern man dreht
einfach ein bisschen dran rum an den Settings,
also nicht vom Kopfhörer,
sondern an der Player-Software oder sonst wo
und stellt das halt ein bisschen ein.
Wenn man ein bisschen zu viel Bass hat,
macht man halt ein bisschen die unteren
Frequenzen runter.
Da kannst du auch...
Da würde ich
nicht den Kopfhörer wechseln für.
Außerdem,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen stehen ja viele Leute
auf so Badewanne beim Sound.
... haben natürlich bewusst diese verrückten
Preissprünge gemacht, um zu verdeutlichen,
dass das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis am Anfang
echt rapide zunimmt, dann abflacht
und am Ende eigentlich gar nicht mehr
im finanziellen Verhältnis steht.
Aber natürlich klingen die HE1 annähernd perfekt,
aber nicht um 65.000 Euro
besser als die Focal Utopia.
Und die wiederum
nicht mehr als 4.000 Euro besser als
die AirPods Max, wenn man das in Euro
vergleichen kann. Irgendwann erreicht
man einfach die berühmten 80%
Leistung, die ja schon sehr ordentlich sind.
Bis dahin sind Qualitätssprünge
auch oft noch nachvollziehbar,
aber für die letzten 20%
zahlt ihr dann einfach teilweise ein
Vielfaches mehr. Und so ist es auch
bei den HE1. Sie sind natürlich die
besten Lautsprecher, die ich je auf meinem Kopf hatte.
Aber sie sind keine
Quantensprünge von anderen
sehr hochwertigen Kopfhörern entfernt.
Und nein, sie haben mir auch keine Tränen in die Augen
gespült. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch immer eine sehr
individuelle, emotionale Reaktion.
Das ist vor allem irgendein Marketing-Bullshit.
Verstehe auch nicht, warum das
heute so beliebt ist für irgendwelche Marketing-Sachen,
dass die Leute vor Emotionen immer
gleich anfangen müssen zu heulen.
Bei fucking
Windows 11 haben die auch fast geheult.
Die heulen wegen dem Preis wahrscheinlich.
Es ist einfach nicht so,
dass man da jetzt etwas Magisches
hört. So, dass man wirklich das Gefühl hat,
oh mein Gott, das ist doch gar nicht
möglich. Fakt ist, weder
die Focal Utopia noch die Sennheiser
HE1 bieten einen
unvorstellbaren Klang. Sie beeindrucken.
Absolut. Aber sie lassen euch nicht
glauben, dass ihr etwas Übermenschliches
hört. Und dieser Eindruck wird mir von vielen
YouTube-Testern, audiophilen Magazinen
und einigen Experten einfach zu oft
vermittelt. Die HE1 sprechen einfach ein
sehr besonderes, exklusives
Genie in die Hand. Das bedeutet aber nicht, wenn
ihr euch die Teile nicht leisten könnt fürs
eigene Wohnzimmer, dass ihr vielleicht
was Großartiges verpasst. Für die
meisten würde ich sogar sagen, trifft das Gegenteil zu.
Kopfhörer wie die Sonys oder die Airpods,
die sind selbstverständlich aufgrund ihres
ganz anderen Einsatzgebietes natürlich auch
viel alltagstauglicher. Ragman, da gäbe ich dir recht.
Ja, man muss einfach nur mal
gucken, was sie in einem ordentlichen
Audio-Studio haben. Da ist nichts mit
Marmorplatten aus Steinmetz und
irgendwelchen
Gold-Platin,
Gold-veredelten
sonst wie Kabel und so.
Da ist einfach ganz solides
High-End
Studio-Equipment am Start. Das ist nicht billig,
aber das sind keine 70.000 Euro
Kopfhörer.
Also in Studios sehr beliebt vor einer ganzen
Weile waren unter anderem sowas
wie Biodynamics
DT 990 oder
770 oder sowas in der Richtung.
Wir hören mal mit, wie
die Aufnahmen sind.
Das sind Kopfhörer im Bereich
von 150
bis 350 Euro.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was
ein DT 990
zurzeit kostet.
Also wenn es so Dinger
für ein Audio-Studio tun,
das ihr nicht verpasst habt,
wenn ihr eben niemals in den Genuss kommt,
solche Kopfhörer wirklich mal zu hören.
Okay.
Abruptes Hände, aber kein schlechtes
Video. Chatge, ich hab Hunger.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Nudel mit Lachs
awaits.
Vielleicht hören wir uns am Mittag nochmal
und wir gucken uns
die sechste Season von Battlefield
2042 an.
Weil auf MW3 halte ich
geistig nicht aus.
Also bis dahin Leute, macht's gut. See you.